foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
is faster and more exhilarating in chess
than a bullet game it's all about quick
thinking and taking advantage of every
opportunity when it comes blink and
you'll miss it how did he do that
despite his popularity bullet chess only
has one annual championship tournament
and now entering its fifth year the
bullet Chess Championship is stronger
than ever three-time Champion Hikaru
Nakamura again looks to defend his title
and add to his impressive trophy case a
brutal finish Nakamura fish
the only player who has ever stopped
Nakamura in this event also returns to
take another shot at it 2021 Champion
alireza farugia that's it competing with
these champions for the first time in
the format the best all-around player in
the world Magnus Carlson has dominated
chess seemingly forever but he's never
played in the bullet Chess Championship
will one of these big three of bullet
take home the twenty thousand dollar
crown or can someone else claim the
title maybe Nara ditsky Tang Hansen
Carolina
that is the Fabiano finale in this
speediest of speed chess championships
only one Champion will emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
welcome to the bullet Chess Championship
we could not be more excited it's an
amazing field it will be electric
competition I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me as Grandmaster Simon
Williams Simon I'm pumped how stoked are
you
I'm really really excited about this
we've got some of the best players in
the world playing probably the most
exciting format we can imagine and uh
Robert is going to be fast and furious
right really fast and furious
oh there are too many you know editions
of that film but not bad to add another
fast and furious event to the mix and it
is the bullet Chess Championship so why
don't we Dive Right In let everybody
know what they're getting acquainted
with as this is just the first day a
hundred thousand dollars in total prizes
the Premier International bullet chess
event with 10 players having been
invited six players had to work their
way into the competition and of course
in the world of online chess Hikaru
Nakamura is a name that rings out to the
masses he has won three out of four
titles so Simon as we enter this 2023
Edition Hikaru Nakamura is he your man
to beat
yeah he must be I mean he is uh the best
online Bullet player I mean okay I say
that there's going to be one guy at
least in this competition who might
argue with that point uh but he's
phenomenal and he has the track record
here so he must be the favorite to to
win this whole event uh but mentioning
that other guy Robert
um you know you know the guy I meant
mean he's quite famous right uh I can't
tell if you mean danielsky Andrew tank I
saw them in the start of video
um or is it a certain Norwegian
I think it might be that Norwegian guy
and it's so exciting that he's actually
playing uh in this event the best player
I would say the best player of all time
I mean you might argue with that but he
is brilliant Magnus Carlson and he's
very good at all time limits he's the
best the classical chess and uh we're
gonna find out if he's the best at one
minute as well uh yeah it's gonna be so
exciting I just can't wait for his match
Robert well some of the names on this
screen should jump out to you we have
Fabiano caruana oh there is a Fairuza
some top five players in classical chess
along with Magnus and Hikaru uh Anish
giri is in the mix but Simon of all
these matches is it the Magnus Carlson
Eric Hansen match that sticks out most
to you
I think it is I mean it's going to be a
very hard match for Eric
um being the low rated player But Eric
does have you know this really good
history of being a very good content
creator very charismatic player very
good at bullet chess but you know let's
be honest um Magnus is that level above
but I you know the thing for me is I
just love seeing the best player play I
love seeing the openings he plays I love
seeing the tactics he comes up with and
um how how he will perform we're yet to
see but uh that's going to be a match
I'm very excited with I I hope Eric gets
some points on the board there and I
will be cheering for Eric as well
because it's going to be you know it
could be one-way traffic but yeah that
one for me is the match that I'm most
looking forward to and what about
yourself Robert do you have uh do you
have one or two matches that you're
you're eyeing up there well I'll see you
and raise you I have three matches that
I'm very excited about nishikiri taking
a Jose Martinez Jasper has won a couple
bullet brawls this year already so he's
a beast and a niche being the super
Grand Master he is a Tang versus
undraken it's they run her up from a
year ago against andrekin who's a super
gym who's playing the candidates and
then of course we have so many other
matchups but Min lay against Arjun Eric
I see I think that's one where Min is
the favorite but Arjun he rises to the
challenge he's won the junior speeches
championship in the past over 2700
himself so so many great matchups I'm
sorry I had to choose three but we have
two more matchups that we're gonna start
the day with that we haven't discussed
yet so Simon it's alireza farouza the
2021 bullet chess champion against
Dennis lazvik the upstart teenager and
almost under Bortnick the Ukrainian
Superstar strong he is against Fabiano
caruana a former world champion
Challenger he needs no introduction so
what do you make of these two matchups
uh great matches to get us started I
mean we have Ali Razer and Ali Razer is
probably one of the most talked about
chess players out there I mean he was
the guy that Magnus kind of has tipped
uh he's the guy that Magnus wanted to
play for the World Championships he's
facing Dennis who has just performed
incredibly well to win the second
Divinity division of the latest
Champions Tour so this young player I
think he's only 17 years of age is a
real Prodigy and how many times Robert
do we say that Ali raises the older
player it's not often right so that's
that's quite an interesting little
starting match for us yeah it certainly
is there is he's the old veteran of this
field of course uh he's just 20 years
old right he is a youngster uh he is a
prodigious Talent from Iran playing for
France he won this event two years ago
it's his fifth appearance in it and
Simon the number of all numbers that
stand out to me the most
35-21 Peak bullet rating
I mean that's just not a number right I
mean what is that I mean I I dream of
being 25 21 right I mean like 3 5 21. oh
I mean is he serious I mean that that is
the kind of uh ELO rating that you might
see stockfish in the year uh I don't
know 2050 hit right
um I don't know it's probably there
already but it's an incredible rating
and as you mentioned he's won this event
before so he's got to be one of the
favorites Ali Razer to take this down
again yeah Ali razor zero over there he
plays with engine like Precision even in
bullet chess he is such a beast his
opponent no slouch as you mentioned
Dennis lazovic and we'll talk more about
him the teenager from Belarus in a
minute but first let's discuss Fabiano
caruana because he's taking on Alexander
Bortnick Fabi he is the 11th seed in
this competition uh on paper in
classical chess we know that resume he
just won a grand chess Tour event the
super chess classic and just a month ago
he placed ninth a year ago in the bullet
Chess Championship so he's proven that
he can hang with the best he lost to
Andrew tank by just one point but he's
playing Olex under Bortnick so Simon
what do you make of his chances
I'm well you know in this event you have
to say that Alexandra is is going to be
favorite and you wouldn't normally say
that in many matches that Fabiano plays
because he's just one of the best
players in the world there's only a
couple of people you'd normally say are
better than him Magnus being one uh but
not really anyone else so it is strange
bullet chess is a different case of a
fish uh the clock is so important how
you move the mouse so important uh
reaction speed really important I mean
you know I feel like a really old man
just you know just looking at all the
players here and it's going to be
interesting the commentary for me but I
I think Robert we'd have to say that
Fabiano's is not the favorite in this
match I mean would you agree with that I
would certainly agree on board Nick we
we have Alexander on screen right now I
mean his shirt is hypnotizing his play
even more so but if I'm Fabi I'm not
looking at the zoom camera because I may
get lost in a trance and Bortnick he is
Bortnick strong and Danny wrench he
coined that phrase is about the number
one dad according to his mug in the
world but Bortnick he was a finalist
against Hikaru Nakamura in the earliest
of these tournaments so he's really good
he's 32-50 Simon 3250 bullet rating on
chess.com
yeah it's another in insane number I
mean anything over three thousand I I
look at in ore and uh you know to get to
get this rating of so high you know over
three thousand you just have to be a
tremendous player but uh I'm very
excited about these first matches Robert
I mean we're going to be straight in at
the deep end and uh I think there's
gonna be some close stuff uh to start us
off today with yeah I hope you brought
your goggles because we're going to be
swimming in the bullet it's a quadruple
header today we start with these two
matches we will have Magnus Carlson
playing later than day Hikaru Nakamura
Nish gear you name them they're likely
in this field but we start with the
matches of farrugia and Dennis lazovic
and 500 carwana and Olex on the Bortnick
so let's dive right into it the players
I mean they have to be set they have to
be steady because this is 30 minutes of
bullet chess no breaks and Simon you
know you get off to a bad start you tilt
a little bit in the first two games you
do have some time to come back because
this is a win by two format let's not
forget that
yeah that's right so they just got to
get the highest score in the time given
you know after 30 minutes but with any
kind of Blitz including bullet I think
form is so important and you don't want
to get in that downward spiral because
you can get a little bit depressed you
can get a bit like you know pessimistic
about your play I I feel that starting
strong is so important and I think
they're they're ready to kick off right
they're just about it has moves yeah
they're about to begin these matches
really excited about them it's a double
elimination format so even if they lose
their match today they're back tomorrow
in the losers bracket and we as we said
it's win by two so if you're down let's
say about 12 to 11 as time expires the
match continues because it's win by two
in bullet chest that feels more fair uh
you need to prove that you are winning
this match by a margin that's more than
one so let's dive right into the games
when we can because the players have
lifted off
yes that's right and they seem to have
kicked off with the first game straight
away and
um they I think it's getting the right
pace as well Robert at the start you you
need to just get in the vibe you need to
get that pace for the rest of your time
here and uh what do we reckon of the
game between Alexandra and Fabiano here
it looks fairly even at the moment yeah
we will bring these games up on screen
for everybody in a second but the games
are getting underway it's the first game
don't worry everybody 30 minutes above
chess uh the players they'll be playing
quite a lot and as we see here we have
Fabiano with the black pieces against
Bortnick and farooza with the white
pieces against Dennis Lasik Fusia and
Dennis lastman on the left and you can
see the players on the right why is
boarding down so much time that's my
first question
yeah I I'm not sure about that it was
either very powerful I mean also looking
at the position you can see the white
king is very weak there as well look at
those dark squares around it this could
be a great start uh for Fabiano if he
can take this first game yeah he's in
great position on the right side of our
screens here oh he just dropped an
important Pawn oh did you see that
pre-move by border he drops his Queen oh
wow
uh it was all down to the clock though
that first one so Fabiano with First
Blood and they're off again straight
away with the second game and a bit of a
double thin Chateau position we have
here and look at the difference in this
match these two matches on the left side
we had a peaceful draw on the right side
we had Fabiano with the advantage before
bortik dropped his Queen in immense time
trouble so we'll see if Bortnick and
rebound there is no increment here Simon
as I look to the left hand side of the
screen I mean I like where Dennis
lazick's pieces are but the engine
doesn't seem as bothered as I am
yes um it looks like you know that extra
material over there left hand side of
the screen might be favoring alireza and
going oh to Fabiano's game Fabiano must
have a bit of a better position here
with that strong horn in the center of
the board
um but black getting counter play now on
the open file yeah and we see that in
this game between farrugia and lazovic
the advantage is getting Sky High for
Dennis lazwick this teenager you
mentioned it in the Champions chess Tour
event the anxious rapid he won division
two he didn't lose a single game to Sam
Sabian he drew like 13 in a row and
right now with the white pieces Simon it
looks like he's dominating because that
Rook on E7 the King on G80 pieces are
not in good position
yeah I totally agree there and um it's
all about King safety I think in bullet
chess this is one thing that becomes
much more important if you get the
initiative if you get the attack it's
gonna be very offend and look at the
tactics where oh my words he missed it
no he missed his King was on the H1 oh
it backfires you know when you you spot
something you're like oh my point didn't
see that and the Jokers aren't you he
took that pawn on H7 trying to distract
The Rook from its defense of the queen
but Simon he walked right into a deadly
pin
yeah that that is the kind of stuff that
only happens in bullet chess right uh
you're trying to move quickly you don't
have time to double check you just got
to go with your instinct and that's what
makes it so so exciting and um that
gives a bit of a lead to Aly Razer and
things could turn very quickly just like
we saw there turned in a hurry and it's
unfortunate for Lasik but he still has
time to recover and that may tell a tale
Simon because look at this position that
E6 Pawn is dropping that's a fork and it
looks like Al Reza he was fortunate to
win that previous game he was also down
the clock now here in game three he's
just up a clean Exchange
yes yes that does just seem to be a very
good position and this is this is the
problem is it once you lose one bad game
and you can get a bit psychologically
Disturbed and you can start doubting
yourself and you've got to avoid this as
against someone as strong as Ali razor
as well who's not going to be very
forgiving he's just gonna try to destroy
you and okay we see here is now a
two-point Advantage the queen and the
Rook of whites are controlling the
center of the ball black is trying to
get his Rook into the game but this is a
wise choice I feel just trying to
exchange those Rooks off there looking
good for white again yeah it looks great
for weight now he is up a couple ponds
and he stopped any sort of initial
checkmating attacks so it looks like all
everything under control except for the
clock this is what happens in bullet
chess lazovic's actually had on time
yeah it's it's very important this clock
and
we're looking he's so quick isn't he
actually I didn't realize how quick uh
you know I I guess it's with youth the
the younger you are the quicker you are
he grabs another Pawn there and he's
just got to push the apart oh this is
the only thing oh this should be this
should be a win for white yeah because
now you can pre-move it out you saw that
he went Queen C3 he meant to take that
pawn on C2 and unfortunately that
allowed a queen trade that gives alirez
a win and I'll raise a 2021 Champion uh
he needs a little introduction to the
broader Chess World and so why don't we
head on over to the other match now that
alireza has jumped up to a two-point
lead it's not over then as last week can
amount to come back here but we see that
carwana he is now down a point against
Bortnick karwana gets game one but Simon
he needs this one
yes he does I mean you can't get too far
behind and looking at the position
they're both now 20 seconds or under but
white has my favorite Pawn here Robert
and uh we all know how strong that pawn
can be Harry the H Pawn that must be a
queen and all he's won the queen as well
this
oh what happened there did you see that
my words he was winning and he took on
C6 because he probably thought it was
some kind of check but the King was on
f8 so Fabiano he inverted his move order
Simon if he took on C6 first that would
have been a check he would have won that
game but that was just a mistake that
cannot happen in bullet
yeah you can't do that you can't blunder
like that and this is a very bad start
another thing that I think is quite
worrying Robert I've just been looking
at the openings of Alexandra and as
white he's playing the Jabara London
system one of my favorite openings and
he seems to be getting very good
positions out of the opening straight
away and when you're playing bullet
chess if you can get nice easy positions
to play as white seems to have here nice
central control look at the H Pawn
cramping Black's King it makes things
very difficult for your opponent so uh
Fabiano normally a strong opening player
but maybe not the case at the moment no
I mean Fabiano he knows he has his work
cut out for him he knows that in time
scrambles that Bortnick will be the
favorite but Fabi has had good positions
and that's what the stronger players can
count on is maybe obtaining an advantage
in the early going of the games but then
when it comes to the scrambles you need
to be able to keep Pace that's why I
mentioned in each Geary he's somebody
who can do it all Fabiano seems he
struggles when under the rest of the
clock
yeah yes I mean when you get to that 20
second Mark and under it just becomes a
different game that's where I kind of
freak out Robert you know if I get under
27 20 20 seconds I just start shaking I
just can't move the pieces and what's
happening on the board well now black is
a pawn up so Fabiano again with a good
position can he convert this one
uh he now oh Bobby is the black pieces
in this game Sorry I was looking at from
the white side he is doing extremely
well and watch out for some Perpetual
checks no he's got everything covered
Simon he should be able whoa wait boring
just gives up a rook why is the
recording D3 not C3
oh it's just a big big blunder there and
they have an equal ending but with look
at the clock you just gotta keep your
eyes on the clock and I like what Fabian
is doing he's just moving his King
backwards and forwards he's gonna come
down to the clock though Robert yeah
queen of four checks apparently a losing
move but who cares I guess Bortnick
cares he's gonna win this on the board
potentially oh
wow unbelievable he does he wins he
actually wins on time but uh that it's
that was absolute chaos there and um we
see now that Fabiano is starting to
drift a little bit here yeah and we see
GM narodisky in the chat welcome Daniel
saying is this what awaits me in 40
minutes yeah it's gonna be chaos and you
better be ready down there go go eat
something come on get yourself hyped for
these matches
yeah we're all going to be very excited
to see Daniel play
um one of the fastest players around but
how do you prepare for something like
this I mean I'm having coffee at the
moment Robert I imagine a lot of strong
coffee might help or something a bit
more chilled out to calm you down I
don't play that much bullets I do not
have all the answers Simon but uh what I
know this I can say for sure is Bortnick
is an absolute Beast I mean he is up
four to one on Fabiano caruana Fabi he
may not be known for his skills in the
quickest of time patrols but last year
just one year ago he took Andrew tank
down the wire Tang only beat him by one
point as tank went on to become the
runner-up of this event but in this
position right now Simon I do like it
for Fabi there are threats against the
black king the white king is safer which
is super important in bullet chess and
look at the clock Fabi well ahead
yeah I'm agreeing and this could be the
way the match is going right a little
bit Robert that
um you know Fabiano is getting good
positions I mean this is a really really
strong position you're a pawn up your
Rook is dominating born look at the
white king running into Black's
structure but you've got to convert it
and you're also up by 13 seconds Fabi
needs to win this game right he must win
this game yeah this one he has I think
Bortnick wants to resign but there's
that match clock element Simon so how
early do you go for overall match
strategy where you just don't resign to
waste time off the clock
yeah it's an interesting strategy
because they do have a set amount of
time and uh if you're up on time you
might as well let your clock tick down
and and I also like again the openings
that um autonic is playing I mean of
course he's pushing the H board how can
I not like that but I think aggression
being the attacker is the way to play in
this timing look at that H file I would
be terrified here in this position
Robert if the queen just lands next to
the black king it's gonna be Checkmate
this is scary very scary I'm scared as
well the one thing that's maybe even
scared in this position is Fabiano
caruana's extensive preparation the eval
bar is not two phased right saying it's
slightly better for white but nothing
major black is up a pawn and White's
King is still in the center so that
gives Fabi chances we just want to
update everybody in the other match as
well alireza currently running away with
it he's up four and a half to half and
look like he's about to win another game
so uh we'll keep our eyes on both these
matches but Simon castling Queen side
and suddenly black is almost winning
well I mean it's a complete mess the
computer might say this is winning but I
would be awesome
did you see that when he went Queen F7
there was Rook h a check one of those
sick Rook sacrifices to win the queen
lovely idea there Robert and now black
with this lovely night Retreat is
winning more material so Fabiano is he
getting a bit of a run going here it
looks like it but he has to be worried
because Knight takes he tried Quincy if
I was check so he throws an 83 in first
yes you know what I'm gonna keep my king
as safe as possible but is his King
actually safe along the file
this is a complete mess and again white
has the initiative black is a piece art
but look at the black king there and
white just covering a second rank any
result possible but White's first rank
very weak and the Queen's Roth this is
looking so good for Fabi but the clock
is important there goes peace watch out
for Rook do you want me Rook idea is
hanging so he had to go for this order
and look at the clock is Fabi gonna win
on time
well that'd be that'll be a first if he
won on time can he do it he has he did
it it's one more time
did you see bordick he grabbed his Mouse
we've all done that Simon how many times
have you been like come on Mouse why
don't you move faster
we're all like blaming our losses on
something else apart from our rubbish
play Don't We I'm an expert at that it
could be the mouse it could be the
computer it could be something
um but it that means two games in a row
uh for Fabi so he's well in this match
at the moment only one point in it
yeah when he was down four to one I
almost wrote him off I was gonna be like
Bortnick has this in the bag but this is
what happens when these super gems play
when they start feeling it when they get
in Rhythm that's when it gets dangerous
for their opponent speaking of Rhythm
look at that Knight on A5 for fobby into
C6 ouch
writes into black Scots there and uh I
don't know that I can black grab that
pawn the evaluation part does not like
it and there we go Black's pieces are
just in too much trouble over there and
Bishop F1 is another idea for like
trying to trap The Black Queen nearly
Rook C3 does that trap the queen this
could be another win Fabiano here you
can just take it yeah look at this I
mean what lovely play from Fabi I mean
this is surprising because he was down a
lot sometimes players get tilted but
Fabi has proven that he is improving as
a speed chess player
he is he's getting better and better
he's got the extra piece here and as
long as he stays up on the clock which
is doing a very good job of he doesn't
need to do anything else really you know
just exchange pieces off you can
exchange the queen get your pieces into
the position and you should win this
game to go for all and I like the way
he's playing this uh Robert The Rook now
coming into into the structure
yeah this is pretty nice play from Fabi
I mean he's so active here Queen 66
spotting tactics and rookie seven to
follow
beautiful tax it's gonna be Checkmate
now because the white Rook is gonna come
into the position so it's floral and
this is this is a free games in a row
right amazing stuff from Fabi
I don't think I've ever seen Bortnick
three lose three bullet games in a row
like the guy is just a beast Robert I'm
sorry to jump into this position I know
this position well and this is a
standard trick in the jibaba London I
even I know this trick how can Fabi one
of the best players in the world be
falling for this you take the bishop you
go G5 black is lost I really don't
understand somebody's opening play it's
it's very very surprising
and he wears King to F7 he should
probably Queen E7 probably but this is
bad and you know what Simon I guess it
pays to do these courses because I know
Bortnick and Dunn did a course together
on the jabala London so it's clearly
paying dividends with Black's King on E7
this looks like honestly I hate to say
it but it looks like a newcomer is
playing with the black pieces here
it's actually quite a standard trick and
it's some trick that a lot of players
should know but you know when you this
might be just a bit of bad preparation
for fabiani because I know that both
Nick plays this opening all the time so
why not have someone prepared against it
and he's dropped his role from losing
that game so uh he needs to bounce back
with the white pieces to even the score
now and it's one of those things right
where you're winning a bunch of games in
a row not saying he felt Invincible but
you just think that hey I got this and
then suddenly you're hit with a punch
right across the face and you're like oh
okay maybe I was just stunned there for
a moment can he bounce back as the
essential question
yeah and he's pulling down now black
dominating on the king side using the H
Pawn to call some more ideas over there
look at Black's pieces that black knight
right in the center very nice piece the
black Brooks also looking good and it's
an extra Pawn so looking very very good
for Alexandra in this game and um
if I was white I'd maybe try to get the
Queens off here but does black have a
big
shots here so kind of position there
might be a tactic yeah I'm looking for
the moment 95 there it is one he Nets an
exchange here
yeah yeah and this is uh this is a big
big move here not surprising Black's
position was so good and Fabiano just
resigned so in the space if in a blink
of an eye he's lost two games but what
this also this is a really bad variation
for black this is losing for black this
opening I've looked at this and black is
just completely lost
um and I don't know what Fabiano's doing
okay he's kind of survived it but the
initiative that white has is phenomenal
in these structures Robert very strange
play in the opening as you said it's
just over look at this just dominating
down the edge file he's barrels down
he's winning the H Pawn and that's just
Checkmate for the black king So Simon I
think you were correct to call it out
sometimes I know we get a little harsh
especially in speed chess the players
they're making decisions at lightning
speed but look at the King on E5 that's
checkmated up there he it's not King of
the Hill he lost this game
I mean you don't often see such a strong
player's King get in so much trouble
like that right and uh I think if Fabian
is gonna have any chance in this match
he needs to find a solution to the
Jabbar the London I mean it's not
working whatever he's doing so far uh
but he's got the white pieces now
another important game because the flow
is going against him uh in the last
couple of games here huge credit to
Alexander Bortnick so many people would
tilt this match away when they lose
three games in a row they'd be
frustrated they're supposed to be the
stronger player but Bortnick he was able
to right the ship and now he's playing
solid chess he's the faster player Simon
so I think games that go like this and
go longer where there are no weaknesses
in his position he can just flag Fabiano
yeah I agree I mean I think he just
keeps doing what he can do with the
white pieces right because he's causing
a lot of troubles and with the black
pieces just try to be solid and make the
games last as long as possible use that
uh you know the clever game analogy you
mentioned earlier Robert and in this
position I'll try to work out which
color I prefer and I quite like White's
King here I mean that white King has
potential to infiltrate into Black's
position
uh but black now gaining momentum on the
king side with this porn storm over
there so pretty balanced I'd say yeah
and I think for father he should have
brought his King forward even if
objectively there were some issues you
need to play with confidence look his
King went back to B3 then back to C4
then now back to D3 I think he just
isn't moving the correct direction and
he's burning time so bordnic playing
more confidently playing great chess but
B4 was a good strike
that's right he's now got a very
dangerous past a pawn but he's spending
a lot of time getting this position you
need to get the a pawn storming at the
board
but he's lost the a pawn that is big
loss that was his one one big Trump
there uh in the position Robert and
speaking of storming past pawns Here
Comes oh C7 just dropped that's not upon
you want to lose if you're born again
but look at the clock Born Again
slightly ahead he is faster but white is
currently winning especially when he
drops those pieces pre-move you gotta
pre-move oh
that is a very painful loss there I mean
Fabiano doing really well but losing on
time and okay this is what black should
be playing H5 stop that attack as soon
as you can but the score is there any
way back from this Robert the score is
it's 8-4 he needs to strike soon right
yeah he needs a strike now and then now
again and then again after that you're
running out of time we're just 10
minutes and 20 seconds on the match
clock you cannot afford another loss and
the reason we're focused on this match
we know two are going on at the same
time alireza is currently up eight to
two so that match uh you know maybe I
think it just went to nine to two after
the latest game so always are running
away with his match an absolute
demolition from the 2021 bullet chess
champion
yeah I mean uh again when these guys get
on a roll they can just destroy and um
they they're just gaining confidence and
that's something you've got to try and
uh disrupt somehow now this position on
the board seems actually fairly
unbalanced I mean I love opposite side
casting I love a good attacking game uh
as I think you do Robert you you love
your tactics and checkmates which you've
done to me far too often in title
Tuesdays stop doing that please
my apologies Simon you know here here
we're teammates but sometimes even
teammates must be competitors and look
at bortley just throw everything but the
kitchen sink against Fabiano's King but
where are White's pieces right Queen F5
Queen H7 that's the one idea but the
Knight safely retreated F6 and now
there's nothing to it
no this is very nice play for Fabiano
but white oh dear white striking back
oh and it's getting complicated again
but again it comes down to the to the
clock I think right it doesn't matter I
mean Black's doing very well on the
board
um
but the time and it seems like Nick is
just a little bit quicker
oh he's a lot a bit quicker but right
now Fabi has an extra uh rook in this
position he stops the bishop F6
Checkmate but he's just moving too
slowly too gingerly and he is probably
gonna lose on time well well Ginger's
Ginger's not always a bad thing
Ginger can be a positive move as well
but look at that you you are right he's
just a little bit too slow I think to
take this match you know it's just a
couple of seconds always in Alexandra's
um you know side which is uh determining
this match so far
okay we're boarding now up by five I
think that's a
not enough time remaining for Fabi to
really get this comeback you get the
game if there's one second left on the
match clock the next game commences but
I think that we see Bortnick is in
control so why don't we go back to see
how our other match is doing just
because if it's gonna be runaway
victories for the better seeds Bortnick
and farrugia we want to tune in to see a
potential matchup between these guys
right like we we know that farooza is a
monster we know boric's a monster but
when they play each other we don't know
what's going to happen so let's try to
give the audience the spectacle that is
Ali Raza farooza's bullet chess
yeah and I mean uh you know farooza is
just such a great player to watch as
well uh I I love I love the way he
attacks in nearly all of his games he
just goes forwards all steam ahead uh
always and um when he's in the right
Vibe he's so scary and uh this position
wow Queen comes over and can you stop
Checkmate now uh look at those dark
squares I mean just a major threat and
this is uh this is a standard idea if
you move the pawn uh forward the queen
will now sneak into that important
Square on G7 and there's nothing to be
done here at all just a very standard
Checkmate pattern there I want to
quickly note that Dennis lazwick has
recently hit his all-time bullet high of
3151 you see it on the screen this is no
slouch this is not a pushover but Ali
Reza faruza is that good he is just
running away with this match dominating
at 10 and F2 and F Simon we knew he was
the favorite coming in but this is a
stellar performance from farrugia
yeah so I totally agree I mean he's on
fire at the moment and he's got this
match in the bag now and um you know
playing very good chess but you know I I
don't know how it's possible you know
really to to to play so well at this at
this uh time limit I mean do you have
any tips Robert and what should these
guys be doing to to uh to be winning
this event
if I had all the answers I'd probably be
in this competition so maybe we'll have
to ask Don you know the next time we
commentate with him but I think there
are certain things that the players have
to do is one is they have to have their
openings in you know like clockwork they
just need to be able to play their
repertoire even if it's a bit dubious
sometimes we've seen Bortnick play
openings that at the classical level
don't do so well but in bullet people
are going to make mistakes they're not
going to play a perfect game so you can
play suspicious lines you also have to
trust yourself in time trouble and that
might mean just moving it doesn't matter
if it's a good move you just have to
throw moves on the board because we've
seen that perfect is the enemy of the
good in bullet chess you start looking
for the absolute perfect eight move
sequence you may not have time to
execute it so we'll look at this game by
the way from Dennis lesvik he's
checkmated uh far Asia on the back rank
a very well played game from him he's
getting a few points there uh but yeah I
think those are some of the important
tips to use and of course pre-moving you
don't want to do it too early because
Simon how many games have you played
where you pre-moved thinking that your
points is going to capture your piece
and they are they're going to make some
other move and they do something
different and now you just blunder the
game away
yeah I I have to confess I'm not even
sure I've mastered the pre-move uh
scenario I mean whenever I play Blue the
chest it is just so hard to get your
timing right because you can't pre-move
all the time but you must at certain
points so there's a real skill uh that's
not just chess and even just little
things like having the right Mouse you
know is important the speed you move the
pieces I mean all of these guys are
going to be uh making sure they've got
the right setup and it was nice to see
Dennis win that last game I mean he's
clearly a really good talent and we're
gonna have a lot more and look at that
move though that is again you know just
so quickly spotting a tactic there
yeah that was a cruncher from Fairuza
first he took the G pawn and the e-pod
and now Rook takes F6 that is three
sacrifices in a row that all work out
for white
incredible and Andy and he's got how
many pawns he's got now five extra pawns
that you can't get you know just stop
being so greedy you don't need any more
that's enough you know uh and I love the
way he's just moving him down rather
sadistically like Space Invaders into
Black's position there it is you know
maybe it's time to just resign yeah
there's I think that's one if you had it
on your bingo card that Simon would only
say just resign a single time in the
first match of the day and it seems that
you're correct but Simon that was brutal
it was really brutal I mean just the
speed at spotting these tactics I mean I
think another thing that will help your
chest if you're watching this if you
like bullet is to you know you gotta you
gotta try puzzles you've got to get good
at tactics uh so puzzle Rush is there
practice it's a great way of doing it
yeah
so there's a chat there when Ali Reza is
like this there's nothing you can do I
think the only thing you can do is
become Magnus or Hikaru because when
furuja is on form they're probably the
only two players in the planet they can
stop him
I mean but such that's gonna be so
mouth-watering Robert if we get a match
up with these guys and I mean what about
Hikaru versus Magnus can we get that I
mean ah I mean that's I mean everyone
you've got to stay tuned Magnus Carlson
you know he's gonna want to win this so
badly and Hikaru is not going to wanting
to win this let's just put it that way
so I'm just really hoping we're gonna
see that match that'll be
um legendary I feel was the only right
word
yeah I think sometimes in sports that is
over used but here it's perfect because
we have not seen Magnus Carlsen take
part in the bullet Chess Championship
and it's not a foregone conclusion that
we will have Magnus first a car it's
double elimination so that could even
happen in the loser's bracket I mean
think about this why is Magnus why would
Hikaru be a shoe and when there's a
faruga in the field there's a Tang a
naroditski I mean there are no gimmies
some of these matches in the early going
they will be one-sided just because uh
Bortnick and farouza are that much
stronger than Dennis lazovic and five
undercarwana in bullet chess but I think
that Simon throughout this competition
and not just throughout the competition
throughout today let's not forget we
have a quadruple header of matches today
we are going to see some entertaining
bull chess and perhaps some upsets
yes totally right Robert and uh you can
see the counter now for this first
segment and uh in this first segment it
does seem like there's only about a
minute left or so two minutes and um
well I think we know who the match was
window is going to be but our next match
very exciting as well I mean uh every
single match of the day is is just going
to be mouth-watering Prospect
um and you know if we're looking at the
actual chess not really too many
surprises I I guess we were maybe hoping
Fabiano
um would have done more but he was
playing good chess Robert it was just
the clock right it was just a little bit
too slow I think fair to say right oh
very fair to say actually as you were
talking I saw off to the side that he
lost the game he was winning because he
blundered a back rank Checkmate so this
is what happens in bullet you get
frustrated you're trying to move quickly
but then you you know I said perfect is
the enemy of the good but the move still
need to be good because if they're bad
you may just lose on the spot to a night
for work to a mate and I think that
we've seen that in these matches so we
probably just have this final game to go
we see farugia up 10 Bortnick up eight
these have been pretty one-sided fares
and for lazovic for Fabiano they have a
chance tomorrow in the losers bracket
it's a double elimination format but as
we see from arkati there yeah different
levels to these players that's no slight
at the players who are not as
experienced or as strong it's just
Bortnick and fridge are that good
yeah they're just incredible I mean uh
every time I watch these guys you know
you know we're both Grand Masters we get
impressed by people but at this speed
the things they are spotting is is is
just uh it's really very hard to
comprehend sometimes
and they're coming to the end now we can
see
um and I don't think uh I mean how
disappointed you think like uh the two
losers will be uh after this match
yeah it's hard to be disappointed when
you're losing to the caliber player
they're facing but I think for Fabiano
he actually had a chance in the match he
tied the score and then he lost that
game because he didn't know the jabala
London so I think that's where the
frustration sets in I think he knew he
was the underdog barnik is just a better
bullet player than he is but when you
have chances you need to make the most
of them and I mean in this final game on
the right hand side of our screen here
look at Fabiano he's playing a great
game of bullet chess he's also down to
seven seconds so maybe he'll lose on
time but right now he is dominating
I think that's kind of been the the
story of the day really for Fabiano I
mean when he's gone out the opening I
mean unfortunately he wasn't getting out
of the Jabara London as you mentioned
whoever plays uh bottleneck in the
future make sure you've got something
planned against this Jabara London
because he's going to play it he's going
to play it more and more and we've now
come to the end of our first two matches
yes Bortnick wins 14-5 in alireza
farooja look at that Checkmate the king
is then F3 he wins another uh the
champions of their first round matchups
for ruja and Bortnick advancing to
Winners round two and for farouza it was
just dominance from the start
yeah he was just throughout that match
just the better player spotting tactics
quicker and just putting pressure on his
young opponent there and there you know
Dennis is in great form as well so very
dominating performance
yes so far Asia and Bortnick they move
on to the winners uh bracket second
round and then for lazovic and Fabiano
they are still alive in the competition
this is double elimination they will
face each other in the losers bracket so
uh that's all that's happened thus far I
mean it's been a very very exhilarating
30 minutes of bullet chess Simon and
from what you've seen thus far I know we
haven't seen Magnus or hikara today but
were you particularly surprised or
impressed by Bortnick or frusia or is it
just par for the course at this point
I'm I'm very I was very impressed I mean
I think just forget how good these
players are I mean to destroy let's say
you know let's say the right words to
destroy someone as strong as Fabiano by
that score line is phenomenal I mean
Fabiana was getting chances but he was
just a little bit too slow and uh some
maybe some holes in his openings being
shown as well which is the first time
I've ever seen holes and Fabiano's
openings I've never seen that before
yeah that's a really good point that he
was being caught in opening traps
openings he doesn't see in classical
chess and that's the beauty of bullet
that you can get away with some shaky
openings that you would not play in
longer time patrols but our bracket is
being set we know that farouja and
Bortnick move on in the winners bracket
and then we see all the way in the
bottom left of your screen Dennis lesvik
fabina caruana they will square off
tomorrow so the winners of these matches
they face each other the losers they
will uh square off as well but ferrugion
Bortnick after what we just saw Simon I
think that is going to be epic
wow I mean what a match that's gonna be
I mean I I really don't know who to pick
I mean uh farusha it is
phenomenal but woodnik has these tricky
openings and the speed that he plays is
just another as we say in England it's
different gravy
so yeah
well that was like a roast dinner there
I mean they were feasting on their
opponents were far Asia and Bortnick and
frugier happens to have that great mesh
of classical chess success and growing
up online playing at all these chess.com
events since he was a child and so he is
proven to be a worthy competitor at the
top so we're gonna head on over for a
break there are three oh six more
matches but two matches of time so three
more of these sessions to go you do not
go anywhere you will not want to miss
the action from the 2023 bowler Chess
Championship
lower and table bases find all the key
event information including schedules
prizes results news reports player bios
tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
trash kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are delighted to be joined by
super Grand Master Ali Reza faruza one
of the best players on the planet and
one of the best bullet players in a
former bullet chess champion so alireza
first of all congratulations how did
that feel winning by that kind of margin
are the paintings but after ice he's a
very talented player of course
um he's a great bullet player as I
understand but
um I'm sure today he
um today he couldn't perform at his best
so
um yeah that was lucky for me I guess
it looked like a very good performance
early racer and um you're facing botnik
in the next match do you have any uh
like feelings about that match have you
played him many times before
yeah I played against him thousands of
games before of course but uh he's a
he's a bullet monster of everybody knows
is
all the time playing bullet and leeches
and Chester Thomas everywhere but and
I think I have good chances against him
I think overall I have a good scoring in
him but it will be a very close match
and I believe and I will try to prepare
for that
well that's an interesting word just use
other as a prepare so I guess how does
someone prepare for a bullet I think a
lot of people in the audience they play
it but they just are making moves how do
you actually improve at the game
um I try normally to solve some like
causal storms like these kind of quick
puzzles before just to
um switch on the brain and turn on the
brain and after maybe sometimes some
openings for instance against a specific
player today I didn't prepare about the
openings but for instance sometimes
maybe against Hikaru or some other guys
that are really known like nardit scared
that I played thousand games and we play
um specific openings that prepares a bit
but generally you have to be in a good
shape and you have to be sharp before
the match starts that's the most
important thing
and um you you mentioned obviously the
chess skills is it very important to
have a special Mouse because whenever
I'm playing uh I always blame things on
my mouse it's too slow but you have a
special gaming mouse or anything like
that
yeah I have the mouse that is like I'm
very comfortable with I'm playing it
from when I was 10 so but wow I don't
think I don't think that's
the most important thing but okay it
helps if you have like a pro Mouse
gaming promos so but this that's not a
game changer I think Coralville is still
beat everyone with touch but
probably fantasy still play good chess
to say yeah
wow so uh you did to clarify usually
you've had the same Mouse since you were
10 like literally the same exact no I
have the same mother I have the same
model like I buy the return
I don't have the same same Mouse for 10
years now
impressed with
qualification to the mouse but all
but also the game other
I'll let you go but seriously amazing
performance here in the first round
we're so excited to see you back
tomorrow against Bortnick
thank you
and that was super Grand Master alireza
faruza let's not forget the 2021 bullet
chess champion in addition to all of his
other accomplishments in the Chess World
he takes on Bortnick he Simon showed a
lot of respect for Alexander he said
this guy is a monster and we play
thousands of games against each other
yeah it must be really hard like uh when
you've played so many games against one
guy and thousands of games I mean this
is quite a new thing that you get in the
Chess World obviously like you go back
10 20 years you wouldn't have played
Thousand Years the Thousand games a
thousand years a thousand games against
the same player so you get a really good
feeling for the way they play what
they're good at what they're bad at and
do you obviously try to Target that area
um but that's going to be one hell of a
match I think uh coming up there
well you said Target their weaknesses I
would be so curious what people Target
when they're playing alireza or Magnus
or Hikaru in bullochess because I don't
know what their weaknesses are and
others it surely didn't show any today
yeah I mean when you when you are if
you'd ask me what are their weaknesses
what should you target I would have no
idea because whenever I watch them
they're just too good I mean you could
say Obviously against some players you
know they're they're a bit slow you
should Target the time maybe certain
openings you go for maybe try to get
into the ending you know there's certain
things that you can so aim for but it
takes a lot of skill to know what to aim
for
yeah and I love the not to Hikaru giving
him that respect saying he could beat
most of us on a touchpad uh I've
actually seen a car do that you're
typing in moves back on ICC days so like
hey Carl a beast the number one seed for
a reason but he's not up just yet you'll
have to wait till the end of the day to
see a card Nakamura take on immunohanian
but you will be happy about the players
who are about to face off in their
winners bracket round one matchups
Daniel naroditski against David paravian
Andrew Tang against Dimitri on Drake and
Simon what do you make of these two
matchups
I'm really excited about these matchups
I mean I know Dania has a big fan club
out there I mean come on if you're on
Twitch now and you like Daniel put your
hands in the air like you don't care
let's hear it for the great man and so
that that one is going to be fantastic I
mean uh Daniel is a bit of a legend
isn't he Robert
he isn't you're going to be fascinated
to hear this I try to do some research
before the matches guess how many times
Dania and private have played against
each other in bullet chess on chess.com
oh wow okay well let me go for around 1
000. the answer is one they've only
played one game against each other on
chess I was shot like it didn't make any
sense but they just played in a bullet
brawl one time how was that possible
that is shocking you would have thought
they would have played loads of times I
mean they're they're both obviously
great uh Blitz players and they're
playing fighting for prize money on uh
chess.com a lot so you you would imagine
they'd play a lot of times right we're
gonna find out what style suits very
soon yes and Daniel nardiski as you
mentioned he is a fan favorite everybody
should know his name it should be
household at this point the Sensei the
prophet the Dania
3553 Peak bullet rating he was third
place in the last three bullet chess
championships over 60 million views on
YouTube and the commentator of the Year
according to the 2022 chess.com voters
so Simon I mean his accomplishments
there are many but look at him he looks
pretty chill for someone who's about to
play bullet
and he was almost pretty chilled I I
guess you know I mean like he seems
pretty chill to me and that's I mean
maybe he's going completely like insane
on the inside but on the outside he
always has a very calm demeanor which
which certainly certainly helps but
don't let that fool you for his
calculation speed he's incredible at
calculating uh but we also have some
other great matchups as well
um coming up now yeah we do I mean Donya
great calculator speaking of the that
type of player Andrew Tang does that
name ring a bell penguin GM to the
masses uh he is a two-time runner-up in
the BCC over 3 million views on YouTube
he is not as frequent a content creator
or some of the others he recently
graduated from Princeton University
that's part of the reason why he has not
been online as much but we also know
Simon that he plays hyper bullet with
about 10 seconds on the clock
blindfolded there are many Clips out
there that the fans should watch
yeah I'm sorry Robert but there's hyper
bullet I mean this is just like this
should come with a health warning right
I mean they I think someone's coined uh
bullet chess as the crack cocaine of the
Chess World I don't know what that makes
hyper bullet it makes it very unhealthy
and you've got to be a little bit insane
to play with 10 seconds of the clock I
mean that is just mind blowing
completely mind-blowing uh but yeah
Andrew he's a bit of a Legend Online
just the speed that he can move but um
obviously his opponent is also a bit of
a legend as well oh he certainly is
because Andrew tank is going to be the
favorite in his matchup but he's taking
on a super Grand Master somebody who
should not be overlooked in this field
is Dimitri on draken he made it to the
top eight of the global Championship a
year ago that was in Rapid chess he has
won title Tuesdays I mean he's just been
up there in pretty much every
competition including classical chess
when he made a candidates and I believe
that was 2016 if my memory serves me
correctly by doing very well in the
world cup so Dimitri on draken he is a
star he's been on the scene for a while
but he's often a player I feel like that
flies under the radar assignment and
maybe it's because he doesn't play so
many classical events
yeah I mean I I think there's a lot of
players like this who are you know very
talented they're meeting incredibly
tansy incredibly strong but I I totally
agree doesn't maybe get the accolades
that some of the other players do and I
think he prefers to play online or he
plays lots of events online and mini he
regularly
um is up there winning events and doing
very well and um he he he doesn't maybe
play Mainline stuff he plays a bit more
Sidelines but I think he's incredibly
suited uh for some some event like this
and he's just a really strong player I
mean what else can be said he is one of
the best out there yeah when you win
title Tuesdays and he's won many of them
that's clear that you are a great speed
chess player bullet is a different
animal shorter time Patrol but what
Dimitri has going for him is that he's
very principled he's a fantastic
Exquisite end game technique so for
Dimitri on draken you don't want to get
down to a Time scramble purely against
Andrew Tang but you might want to
outplay him when you have about 20
seconds on your clock so it's going to
be very interesting for me to see that
matchup I do think that Dania is a heavy
favorite against David perovian I think
that's why my focus has been more on
Tang versus on draken because I do think
that on drinking has serious chances now
that I say it I'm guessing Andrew's
gonna run away with it
yeah I just think it's going to be a
very interesting match I mean uh you
know chess wise you would say that uh
Dimitri is the stronger player there's
no offense meant against Andrew I'd love
the way Andrew plays but Andrew is is
not just a chess player he's got other
things in his life and uh hasn't got the
experience of Dimitri but Andrew is a
very special bullet player and we're off
we are off indeed we see both matches
side by side and the left side we see
Daniel naritzki that's Dania playing
David perravian and the right side we
see Andrew Tang against undrakin so
early stages here the first game of the
matches I think I need a calm down Simon
I'm so excited about these two
yeah I mean they're awesome it's gonna
be very very exciting and fascinating to
see how these matches get on I think I'm
with you on your general sort of
predictions I I do think that Daniel is
a big favorite
um he's just uh you know been number one
on chess.com he's got all that
experience and the other match between
Andrew tank and uh Dimitri adriagin I
think is going to be fascinating you
know and I'm just looking at the moves
that have been played there and uh so
far seems fairly even it's just getting
the right Rhythm I think at the start of
this match you've gotta start cracking
straight away with the tactics and
spotting things immediately right and
speaking of tactics and spelling things
look at Daniel he trades Rooks he pushes
his Pawn he forces a piece up ending and
the way he's playing this is excellent
but it's a little bit tricky you see
Donna he's struggling a little bit and
this is why watch out for the past B
Pawn
yeah and um you know again it's getting
in the right Vibe uh that pass beep on a
little bit dangerous but I think Anya
has it all under control there he does
have the extra bishop and indeed he's
won that first game to already uh take a
little mini lead in the match but the
other position very interesting there we
get to an ending and this is where you
thought exactly in this situation where
Dmitry might have his biggest Advantage
right that's exactly these types of
positions unfortunately for him he's
down a pawn right now but I'm looking at
the clock Dimitri about level on the
clock with Andrew let's see if he can
keep up that pace
yeah this is going to be a really good
test and it looks like Andrew just
blundered a pawn there and uh now if
anything I kind of prefer Black's
position but okay he blunder support him
back that should be a draw opposite kind
of Bishops they've only got one Pawn
left but it really is a draw in bullet
chess and there goes a pawn this is
where I would have thought Andrew should
be big favorite he's quick he's fast
he's tactical he's a stew obviously a
drawn position here but he wins on time
that's something that
Dimitri's got to avoid those kind of
situations right exactly that I don't
want him to be in a position where it's
locked up and nothing can be done and
he's just going to get flagged because
that is what's going to happen Time
After Time what he needs is to build
those little advantages I think Andrew
played a great game I was you know we
were following it from the start we saw
the position I think Andrew was very
controlled he made some mistakes that's
going to happen in bullet but I think he
was never in any danger whatsoever in
that first game but in this second game
it looks like he's in big danger with
black
wait what was that I loved he's giving
away peace
yeah why might give I mean I was
wondering where is where White's
compensation was in this position I mean
the black king is not castled white has
the open file white has some dangerous
Knights so actually even though it's a
piece down it will be easier for white
to play Robert and look at that night
coming straight into the guts of Black's
position are the white Knights are
dancing Robert there they are dancing
around now it's a really good
explanation by you Simon that it may
objectively be good for black winning a
piece but easier to play especially in
bullet look at the lead in The Clock the
disposition already looks good for white
from a chess perspective but from a
bullet perspective he's up 15 plus
seconds with the white pieces on draken
that's a free piece of it and you can
see that that induced the blunder from
Andrew there it's so much easier to
attack just remember that when you're
playing try to get the initiative it
counts for a lot in these situations and
uh we're into the next game interesting
King's Indian defense here
yeah and I think it's one of my biggest
struggles sometimes is sometimes I'm a
little too chest focused and then I have
to look at the clock and be like wait a
second this isn't a classical game
Robert speed up this is when I'm playing
bullet myself it's not about having the
advantage so much as you know keeping
control keeping pace and speaking of
pace look at the blistering start from
Tang he's playing instantly he's opened
up Black's King Simon this is exactly
what you were calling for
yeah and uh also I think it was a good
call for you Robert that this match
might be very close I mean everything
I've seen so far is really not much uh
it's separating these two players
Black's now getting a little bit of
count Sprite Rook has dived in the black
queen you know we have a tactic there
but I don't see why that works white
material up and that last move shows
that the black king is also very weak
when you lose the bishop around Jewel
King the fiend Chateau Bishop there your
king becomes a real Target and uh well
Andrew's got everything he wants here oh
Rook A3 hitting the queen but also a
rook lift you just know that Rook is
gonna swing on over to the king's side
so I think Dimitri just should have
blundered when Rook takes E2 I don't
think he realized the Knight on D4 could
take back I like that but now he's just
in trouble watch out for Knight G4
checks there is something against that
white king
there is maybe there's a knight F5 and
you can swing The Rook around something
like that but uh the white king should
be pretty safe it's got two Pawn
protection a wise idea here trying to
get the Queens off the board and uh
White's still completely dominating and
that's the killer tactic getting rid of
The Rook
yeah take away all the aggressive pieces
now a weight is up a clean exchange make
that a rook once E4 drops as it just has
and so it's a win for Andrew tang and a
nice game but this feels like a fight
that was a really good game wasn't it
that was just a class class game there
and it is going to be a fight Andrew
Tang now one point up at the moment and
we just have a look how Daniel is doing
and the score in that match I'm just
trying to get an update for everyone is
uh okay I think Daniel's down on points
is that right
whoa I know that he got an early win I
think he might be two and a half one and
a half in that one so it's close there
as well and so let's uh you know when we
can go to our scene with both boards at
once I know it's a lot to take in for
spectators because moves are happening
very quickly and uh the evaluation bar
is like a seesaw going up and down but
down it actually is up to an F1 F and is
he up two pieces for a rook in this
position and like three extra pawns yes
he is on the left hand side of the
screen
yeah but that match um at the moment
going a lot closer than we had predicted
there and a little bit worrying for
Daniel fans I mean I think most people
predicted that Daniel would uh win that
match reasonably easily
um exciting position on the other board
as well with a black king only now
getting to some safety yeah what is
happening in that one it looks oh Bishop
A6 played by andrekin and then giving up
the E6 Pawn but you keep talking about
Simon I think it's a really astute point
that King safety is so essential in
these bullet games and I'm looking at
the clock on the right hand side and
draken he's about even on time he's
going to need to speed up even if it
costs him some of his advantage
speed up here and this is where I think
Andrew's got the biggest uh sort of uh
um positive
results coming when he's in this
situation it just comes down to the
block and you can see 11 seconds now
okay the Queens are off the board but
Dimitri has to play quicker we got
another opposite color Bishop position
and last time this happened same
situation Andrew Tang took it and now
he's won a piece yeah he's too fast and
oh whatever background checkmate
oh he just defended in time there
yeah really nicely done by tang and he's
well ahead in the clock he is going to
flag on drinking but don't blunder C7
Checkmate that's the one thing you need
to avoid and he wins and the clock does
tank
yeah Andrew just too quick at this
moment in time and that's very important
and then the other match okay looks like
Daniel does have a bit of a lead on
points there so he's trying to exerts
his dominance
well Province fighting back Simon
yes yeah he is yeah how's game going on
there I love the pushing of the H board
here but maybe it's a little bit too
much I don't know would you be pushing
your H pawns like that take him with the
King
oh my gosh the right hand side is crazy
the left-hand side the evaluation keeps
changing and whoa Andrew Tang is just
ripping on Dragon's position to shreds
on the right hand side of her screen
very good way to describe it
absolutely that was absolute Carnage
that was I mean what's happening here I
mean he he is ripping the position apart
and he could have won the queen there he
missed Queen takes Queen he could have
won
but he doesn't even need it does he it
doesn't even answer normally we'd be a
bit critical you need to take the free
Queens your offered but it's Andrew Tang
uh he can be forgiven because he just
Checkmate his opponent and look at this
by the way Dania he is so fast he is
fighting back he's trying to stalemate
himself and he's not gonna get it he he
he does not Auto Queen he said gets a
knight but he is going to lose this game
by Checkmate paravian steals that one
yeah that was great great okay uh and uh
only one point in him that much say very
very close and that does seem like the
closer match though at the moment
school-wise a bit surprising considering
the start of these two matches it looks
like on draken was right there neck and
neck with tang and what is happening
Simon they're playing your type of match
on the right hand side of our screen
yeah
well I love these peace sacrifices then
again it I think it goes back to that
having the initiative
um you don't even need to count points
so much as long as you're the side
attacking who's got the safer King well
the white king is pretty safe Castle but
Black's King is stuck in the middle and
I really don't like Andrew's position
here and he's tried to sacrifice some
material back to get his King safe will
he manage the castle Queen side there's
only one move away from it that might
help him a little bit but
he can't Castle now because you would
take the Knight there okay he's not
getting checkmated he's got a little bit
better for him oh but taking little
Knights take both nights and then Rook
f8 check wins her The Rook on A8 but he
doesn't go for it and now suddenly
Andrew Tang who was completely busted is
still in this game but he is down a few
seconds
can a dragon finally take one
yeah he needs to take this one again to
have any chance at all they've still got
20 minutes left so
um there's a long time but when I say he
needs to take a step any chance he needs
to get a roll guy he got checkmated at
the bottom right Brook H2 is mate and on
draken is beside himself he laughs so he
doesn't cry
uh sometimes you have to laugh so you
don't cry writing that was the the
so-called Arabian chick mate there the
oldest ever recorded Checkmate in chess
and they go back to their battles in the
king's England defense now
well instead of cutting the deficit to
two it is ballooned to four so Andrew
Tang is in charge which means for the
moment we'll focus on the left-hand side
of our screen we'll the matchup between
naroditski and paravian paravian right
in this thing and we see you chat we
know you just voted and you said that
the mouse is very very important in
bullet uh I think that frugier said yeah
you know it doesn't matter so much but I
think that the chat disagrees they think
that their Mouse is their main weapon
when it comes to Bullet
yeah I mean it certainly helps right
unless you are the Hikaru nakamura's of
the world and
um
we're just uh yeah we can have a look on
Daniel's match now because that is a bit
of the closer match that's going on and
uh seems like Daniel's getting in the
zone a bit and I like his position in
this game
oh yeah look at this position where
white pieces are staring into Black's
Advanced bonds blasting actually safe
despite the fact that there are a few
Pawns in front of it so I mean this
seems like complete control in this game
from Daniel
I love the way you describe those pawns
there Robert those Pawns of blacks are
just like blockers but they're also
Dynamic blockers because the black ones
at some point can throw themselves
forwards and there you go it froze
itself forwards and the black queen
enters into the position uh the black
king well I think White's only chance is
to somehow get some Perpetual but it's
not gonna work and this is a I've got a
beat healing position for black okay
White's trying trying to get the queen
in
Queen H2 it's made in one
yeah Queen H2 okay but you see what Don
is doing he's not playing it because he
wants to waist match clock that is an
experience commentator of many speeches
Championship matches
maybe his opponent should be resigning
then and we see again the Jabara London
they're loving this opening uh Robert
it's been played so much I mean
um Daniel loves playing it all the time
as well yeah this isn't a paid
advertisement but Daniel and Bortnick
created a course together on the jabala
London they actually spent quite a lot
of time in person working on our very
close friends with Dania so I know that
they met up they worked really hard on
it and it's clearly paying off because
they're getting good positions and look
at White's position in this game this is
like a dream London where you have that
Knight entrenched on C5 and you control
the dark squares
yeah it's all about pieces and Pawns of
course Jess and uh well actually it's
turning a little bit now blacks Bishops
becoming quite powerful
um actually I like Black's Bishops all
of a sudden but what a quality move that
is getting rid of one of the Bishops and
just heading for an ending where white
is very active with the rook and the
Knight there gotta stop the black porn
though
it's a good way to stop it from Simon
right in end games Knights just often
are better than Bishops especially in
bullet chess uh Bishops being long range
Pieces good when their pawns are both
sides of the board like this position
but how many times have we seen someone
blunder and nightfork
it's a good point actually I mean I I
guess in bullet chairs she'd prefer to
have the Knight than the bishop but
maybe in classical chess we prefer to
have the bishop I mean in this case the
bishop is dominating because when you've
got pawns on both sides of the board the
bishop is a better piece because it's a
long range piece you can go to both
sides of the board but the Knight is
better when pawns are all on one side of
the board
like she's not winning here though you
know what dinos doing is he's thinking
what would Robert Hess say it's that a
pawn is the wrong color with that Bishop
sacrifice your night for the H Pawn
somehow do it
now yeah
some chances to draw
oh but he can't get to the pawn in time
no very nice place so far technically
waste by David here
forcing the Knight over and now that H
Pawn is running down oh it's oh Knight
G4 would have saved it oh but you know
it's there yeah in no time okay yeah
and very instructive ending there Robert
and very hard to in this time limit go
into much detail but he pointed out
Robert it's actually a technical draw
even though you're four points up in
that ending which is incredible which is
one of the only times that is the case
in chess yeah the problem was the clock
for done you don't say that very often
by the way so credit to David paravian
who is now only down two points he was
speedier than Daniel was that's kind of
surprising
and pour some wind there as well and the
other match seems to be going very much
in Andrew Tang's favor and you can see
uh yeah he's doing well score wise but
yeah Daniel Daniel there
a little bit on the back foot at the
moment
oh Knight D5 what a move by paravian
brilliant move there the Knight diving
in and now the queen can come in as well
another dodgy position here for Daniel
and there goes a pawn yeah this is great
for white that Nate can even go back to
D5 and Simon this is a dream come true
for any night of player from the white
side look at that Bishop on G7 and look
at the Knight on D5 I think we know
which one's better
yeah 100 I mean the the Knight is like
an octopus in the middle of the board
it's tentacles just floating around
everywhere and uh and black though is
getting some counter play because the
white king not entirely safe
and this is something I noticed that
Daniel does a lot he can get a bit of a
dodgy position but he's got such
brilliant tactical Vision causing his
opponent so many problems and actually
now black seems to be doing okay look at
the clock though Dania is well behind on
the clock and that's why he's
jettisoning that beep on please take it
make my life easier to pre-move Rooker
five he walked right into a fork
oh
that was such a nasty trick there
such a nasty trick
there are no words to be said it's what
Donnie does best right he sees tactics
at the quickest of quick paces and he
looks like he's about to take this game
he does yeah that pawn just too strong
there and white loses a very important
game
unbelievable honestly like I was about
to say Simon oh I feel like paravian
despite being worse he might win this
one because he's up seven seconds and
then done it turned it around before I
could even think fully about what I was
going to say
it's just one I mean you know normally
when I play bullet and I'm sure most
people watching you know one tactic
won't necessarily change the result of a
bullet game but at this level it's not
even a tactic it's the smallest of
mistakes that will uh you know cause
Devastation in the position and I have
to say the games we're getting in that
match between Daniel and David are just
really good tactical battles every
single game this piece is flying and
look at the position they have here it's
another one where there's some material
on balance and uh pieces are just
everywhere
yeah these games have been hectic to say
the least and we see that on the left
side near this you have three points
David probably kind of just you know
might have cursed himself a little bit
he seems upset about something and the
right side we have an end game where a
draken is up a piece for two pawns oh
just one Pawn excuse me Simon I feel
like we've seen this a bunch although
Andre can just blind as soon as I said
that
yeah and this is this is the they have a
problem right I mean Andrew is I think
simva to Dan you're in the respect that
he just spots these uh you know tactics
so quickly and um another point to
Andrew there I mean he's dominating that
match at the moment and it's good to see
him play so well
yeah he is back with a vengeance I mean
he really wasn't so active for a while
he just graduated from Princeton
University that's Andrew Tang we're
talking about on the bottom right hand
side of your screen uh but so great to
see him back he has so many fans uh over
the years his long matches with Magnus
his hyper bullet blindfold sessions it's
really awesome to see the penguin GM
back and I don't think we've seen a
penguin this power hungry since Danny
DeVito in the Batman movie
[Laughter]
I do like the old classic Batman so I
have to say you know old school here
with my film uh taste who was your
favorite Batman which actor my favorite
Batman a good question wow
um not Robert Patterson I have to say
um my favorite Batman I think is gonna
oh I don't know you what about you
Robert help me out here well I think I
like The Dark Knight the most but that's
not necessarily because of Christian
Bale even though I thought Christian
Bell was really good in it um you know
Danny is preferential to Val Kilmer
Danny always is shouting out good old
Val definitely not the George Clooney
Batmans I just never really got on board
despite liking the villains if Tommy Lee
Jones Jim Carrey they had some you know
good villains in those but yeah I think
um
that's a good call because uh I love the
doors and I don't know if anyone's seen
where he played Jim Morrison he was
great he was a great Jim Morrison so Val
Kilmer fast actual round and I like the
way we can have a little break from this
chest because sometimes even for the
commentators we need to just talk about
something else otherwise my brain's
gonna explode
it's it's a lot to commentate on well
just like uh Batman I guess we're gonna
Dodge bullets
a lot of things
and um looking at the match it another
well David should win this one uh how
much time do we have left we have 10
minutes left so you know what if David
does win this one he's only two games
behind
no yeah two games behind for 10 minutes
so this is a root this is a close match
very close match it is and by the way
look at the speed from paravian he's up
nearly 20 seconds against Dania
wow and Daniel doing the right thing
just you know waiting till the time
every second counts in these ones but he
must be a little bit nervous I think
Dania with uh this two I think the next
game is going to be very important David
needs to win this one to bring it down
to a one-game deficit but he's got got
the black pieces and he's playing
against the dreaded Jabara London the
Jabara London is just such a good
opening at this time limit is this easy
to play and there's loads of Tricks yeah
now right there's an E4 Pawn that looks
a bit weak that now is gone so it's not
weak anymore and weight is up a pawn two
Bishops against two knights and I think
something we should shout out once more
is why is a one game deficit so
important this is Win by two if you're
from the United States and you played
pick up basketball you know all about
win by two if you're up by one you can't
just say oh I got to 21 it's over no or
11. you're like win by two is uh how
these games these matches excuse me are
one and looks like dania's in trouble
Simon I mean black has the open D file
that Bishop on G7 you have to snap that
C3 Pawn off the board I like Providence
position here
yeah I mean I I think black is is better
here blacks Rook a little bit more
active on the seventh rank good drawing
chances saying that because there's that
saying all rook and pawn endings are
drawn and I'm not sure if black will be
able to win this one but he certainly
got the better better possibility
and that would make it a one just one
game one game between them then which is
nothing
and Donnie's a bit stuck here because he
wants to keep the F7 Pawn under check so
the king can't get up to F5 well now the
king can't move because the Rook moves
the check but I was going to say that
provin was ahead on the clock so if
you're David do you force the draw
immediately or do you maybe play this
hoping for a win I'll Dodge way too fast
I think if I'm playing against Daniel I
just take the draw
because I'm probably worried about I'm
gonna get flagged in this position
actually and um do they take the draw
they take the draw and you see a little
little Shake of the head by David he
realized he should have won that one and
that's the other thing psychologically
you can't let these games affect you you
know if you keep getting a bit negative
thoughts it's gonna it's gonna affect
the way you play the next game just to
remind everyone as well we're only seven
well just over seven minutes away from
the world's best chess player playing
his first bullet competition here Magnus
the great Carson is going to be he's
gonna be playing wow you excited about
that one I'm pumped and he's playing
Eric Hansen so I don't think many people
know who they're gonna root for in that
matchup Magnus being the heavy favorite
uh but Eric Hansen he has put up fights
against all the best players in the
world he in fact beat Magnus in the
Champions chess tour in one of their
games I remember from a year ago and
well you know that one that would be a
huge upset I think paravian's upset
chances they look like they're going out
the window Simon it looks like a g Pawn
is missing from the forces in front of
the white king
yeah there's just a blunder there as you
pointed out and that g Pawn around
White's King there goes an H Pawn and
now Daniel is two pawns up he has nice
time there he's also two points up if he
wins this three points up it's gonna be
too much white needs to try and get some
kind of Miracle here and just not lose
this game I think to have any chance
he's doing the right thing he's trying
to get his King to safety moving it to
the other side of the board
call it doing a Forest Gump you just
gotta run for us run run run for the
hills the Queens are off right
some chances here but I don't know I
mean it's not
look at the time though this is where
Daniel again
oh that's a little bit Yeah well some
chances to draw yeah that f file being
opened definitely gives away some
chances and now you need to be able to
push G4 but the bishop on E6 is not
allowing that to happen
and actually white is fighting really
well here I mean uh you know in some
cases white might be better now
unbelievable white is better White's two
pawns up this is what he needs but he's
got six seconds left
if you can just
avoid losing this the pawn can be
stopped that's a queen
it's too slow though too slow and you
see that look at that
that was wild
I I haven't seen him celebrate like that
Robert uh for a long time that was some
proper class a fist pumping from Daniel
there I mean uh just showing how
important that game was
and well he's got this match now really
in the bag he's three points up there's
not enough time to come back from that
so we know who our winners are and uh
Andrew Tang dominant still in that other
match
yeah look at uh and Drake it's
sacrificing all his pieces going for an
attack but black has like
two extra Pawns in the center and is up
a knight in just one oh gosh that Rook
drops as well Tang is too strong right
now
yeah he's playing Amazing chess and he's
playing Amazing chess really quickly and
that's what you've got to do in this
format you know you can't think too much
you've just got to play and uh well I
say that and uh he has dropped a rook uh
in that one but
not gonna make too much difference with
the whitening being so weak there and
just remind everyone some of the players
we still got to come we still got the
world's best player Magnus Carlson and
then we got maybe the world's best
bullet player Hikaru are lined up so
there's a lot of action still left
by the way Andrew Tang just blundered
everything in that game against Dimitri
on draken on Dragon playing fast even
though he was giving away pieces early
and that has actually worked out for him
so it's a little bit too late but for
the losers bracket is it double
elimination tournament on Dragon should
take away some of these positives from
this match and nerdinski by the way in
that bottom left he just is about to
Checkmate Province King
yeah very and I love the way that Daniel
just doing that he was just waiting
again waiting for his opponent to resign
but there's only two minutes 40 left
there and um Daniel's gonna be going
through to the next round I don't know
like he seems to be drinking various
drinks there Robert I mean or was it the
same drink it's kind of like you know he
was double drinking he had one can and
then he had another can it's like you
know was it caffeine and then water and
caffeine you know Daniel's making sure
he's he's well stocked up on on the
right juices there yeah they always say
you have to be hydrated so don you're
doing uh maybe he's got the tactics
drink and then the positional drink you
know it depends on the type of position
I like that so there's that famous story
Gary Kasparov on his watch wasn't there
I don't even know this one but Gary took
his watch off when he was playing chess
and he'd always put his watch back on
when it was time for his opponent to
resign and you know just resign the
watch goes on
and yeah yeah I'm wondering what drink
that is that's not a drink we have in
England yeah does anyone you know I'm
just intrigued about Daniel's drink
there
I I didn't quite see it but you know it
could have been like a spin drift or
some kind of Seltzer I'd have to get a
glance at the can again or if we
interview him it would be nice to hear
what he has to drink while he's playing
but I think we look at the boards here
in the bottom left Daniel's pushing his
past pawns as he's done all match
yeah and that passport is just too much
and there you go again a nice move
attacking the rook and that pawn becomes
a queen and he's uh he's he's flying now
flying with uh some some great chess at
the moment there goes another one this
has got to be so depressing for uh David
to lose this way because he hasn't
played badly you know his chest has been
okay I mean I think he got a bit
frustrated with himself Robert that
could have been one of the things that
has affected his his uh his game here
completely agreed and I think we have to
say Simon that of the four matches that
we've seen thus far from The Underdogs
per avian has been by far the best I
mean he's really put up a serious fight
against Daniel nerdinski who's often the
number one rated player uh bullet rated
player on the site so uh real huge
credit to paravian for making this such
a match but when all is said and done
Dania he's typically going to win his
matches unless he's playing against the
likes of a a Tang or Nakamura farouza
Carlson and that's what lies ahead of
him in this field
great do you know what they need to get
Robert I think they need to get eye
trackers because uh I'm noticing in this
again just interesting things like where
do they look and how do they look so
quickly you know bullet chess is a
different it's a different kind of game
isn't it classical chess there's other
things you have to think of and their
Vision the speed of their vision is just
incredible you know so it'd be
intriguing to see where where their eyes
are pointing it really is and time is up
this is the last game of each match and
we see that Daniel up a night for just
the pawn on the bottom left although
it's getting complicated with black
being able to secure a pass pawn and the
bottom right on draken hoping for one
last victory against Tang who has just
been too strong and too fast today
yeah time's been very impressive for
maybe being most impressed by Tang
actually because as you say you know
he's been busy with other things not
just chess concentrating what was he
doing at Princeton was it on the markets
or something learning to trade or you
know something along those lines maybe
uh but he seems to be back against
such a strong player as Dimitri
dominating the matches is very
impressive yeah a huge plus score for
Tang I saw an earlier feature chat that
he took on record under three thousand
so he was just farming his super GM
opponent and Tang is going to deliver a
Checkmate it looks like in the final
game Daniel wins his final game so in
the end the spreads were assuming
proving won the final game pardon me uh
but the spreads are significant but
paravin really put up an amazing fight
yeah definitely and uh we see the end
now the other match and that's going to
be checkmates I'm to resign
too late
it's too late I've got to throw it in
occasionally Robert I haven't had a
chance to say it so far
you can blame the guy we see on the
screen in front of us Andrew tank just
plays too quickly for you to be able to
say it he advances to the second round
of the winners bracket he stretches you
know he's like my wrist it feels a
little weary and he's looking like he
could take a nap right now
yeah I think I need a nap after this as
well it's pretty fast and quick and uh
yeah we I believe we're gonna get an
interview with one of the players as
well right I think with Andrew maybe yes
I I hope so when you win 12 and a half
three and a half over Dimitri on draken
your thoughts should be heard Daniel
nerdinsky also moves on but that was the
closest match that we've seen so far 10
F6 and f David perovian he qualified his
way into the competition he proves that
he deserves to be here he played a
really excellent match
yeah he did yeah I mean he played very
well he had actually many chances there
it's a lot closer than uh I think anyone
would imagine that much and maybe it was
just a little bit of speed at the end
and some some sort of uh annoyance he
was getting with his bad play I mean we
all get annoyed when we play badly but
we should try to get annoyed when the
match is over rather than drawing the
match
and we see the last player go up into
the winners quarterfinals that's going
to be tomorrow Daniel naroditski will
take on uh Andrew Tang we already saw
Fusion Bortnick make their way through
paravian and on draken they will duke it
out tomorrow so they lost their matches
and the task barely gets easier but I
think all eyes will be on the winners
quarterfinal matchups because Daniel
naroditsky versus Andrew Tang they face
each other last year in the losers
bracket final Tang took that match so
you know that Daniel will want his
revenge
what a match that is going to be to just
two of the quickest players and
tactically alert players around so where
yeah it's going to be fascinating and I
do see in the chat as well that people
are asking where is Magnus Carlson well
he's going to be here very soon guys we
have to show a little bit of patience I
know that's not normal for bullet chess
but he's coming he's coming here soon
along with Eric Hansen they were not too
long not too far to go no not at all in
fact after this break we'll get an
interview and then Magnus Carlson
against Eric Hansen will start so uh
before we do head to break we're talking
about bullet this is the bullet Chess
Championship let's talk about a weekly
bullet event right here on chess.com
because if you want in on the bullet
chest action now is your chance weekly
you can compete in the community bullet
brawl Arena and win Diamond memberships
anyone is eligible to throw their hat in
the ring and prove their speed chess
prowess all you have to do is join the
Community Club on chess.com and register
for the arena use the command CBB in
chat for all of the details you will not
want to miss bullet brawls which are
open to everyone you also will not want
to miss the interview that we're gonna
get hopefully with Andrew Tang when we
return from this short break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
foreign
becoming a chess streamer like your
favorite creators such as Hikaru Gotham
chess and the botan sisters come on look
at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are joined by the penguin Andrew Tang
Andrew huge congratulations on what was
a demolition honestly how did it feel to
get back in the ring in this bullet
Chess Championship
thanks yeah yeah it feels great
um yeah I've been gone for a while so it
feels really good to be playing
um I mean and what a crazy tournament
it's crazy that you guys got all of us
this year I'm really looking forward to
playing I'll play Magnus e car and Eli
Reza
yeah I said it's a very strong lineup
Andrew and you know you have been away
doing other interesting things but
you're playing Daniel in the next match
um and any thoughts on that one
I think we're both in pretty good form
actually so I don't know I'm just gonna
do some more prep warm up and I think
it'll be a very close match you really
could go either way
and we asked alireza the same question
and you use the same word as prep and he
is explaining how he preps for bullet
chess how do you do that
I mean usually I just do some warm-up
but I really feel like try Harding I
guess when I look at some lines and
we've played a lot of the times and just
be a little extra ready
for what we might play I guess
and Andrew is there anyone in the world
who's quicker than you with the mouse
or are you the quickest
I don't know it's getting closer these
days there's some more young kids who
are playing Ultra bullet and so far it's
still the highest rating but some of
them are starting to catch up in Mouse
speed so I'm a little bit scared
and you know you said you've been off
doing other things we know you just
graduated congratulations on that but
how how do you get right back into
bullet form because I feel like form is
a very important word when it comes to
Bullet
yeah so I was gone for like a month in
Asia on vacation with my friends on a
grad trip and after I came back I I felt
like I was playing I don't know like a
hundred points
worse for like five days but I just kept
playing and I think I've gotten all the
speed and all the feeling back which is
really all that you need I think in the
bullet
Andrew I mean you do seem so relaxed
when I taught you in interviews but
um when you play chess it's the opposite
right uh do you you have to like just
change gear is there any magic thing you
do when you're playing get in the zone
anything you do to get in the zone when
you play
um not really I think yeah I'm just very
good at being calm in general like
well at the Army dead end tournament we
were both at recently my heart rate
stayed pretty pretty calm the whole time
um yeah I can kind of just turn on Zen
mode and
I'm just very good at focusing I guess
when I need to
yeah well pretty much Zen mode you've
mentioned travels in Asia so I gotta ask
you where in Asia did you travel to with
your friends
yeah so I went to Japan
uh Taiwan Thailand Singapore and Hong
Kong so
it was a long long trip I was gone for
over over a month just uh traveling all
around Asia
did you play any chess over there
um I tried playing some bullet
tournaments like I played a bullet brawl
but I don't know I understand the pain
that some of the Asian players go
through when they're playing at like 2
A.M but uh yeah uh just a few bullet
tournaments really
well it's not 2 A.M this time it sounds
like you had a lot of fun I'm kind of
jealous because I've been you know
seated in chairs commentating so hope it
was a blast and hope it continues to be
a blast in the bullet scene because you
have work cut out for you against Donna
tomorrow so we look forward to seeing
you in that matchup
all right thank you Andrew appreciate
your time as
kill right like he has been on vacation
he's been just around the world with
friends he's playing bullet brawls at
two in the morning and yet he is coming
back and winning matches against Dimitri
on draken by a nine point margin Simon
like I wish that when I took a break for
that long time I could you know beat the
newest players on the site but I just
sometimes can't and he is just an
absolute Beast
yeah I think Beast is the right word and
what amazes me uh Robert is how how calm
he really is like in these interviews
you know he's very softly spoken uh
composed but when he plays chess it's
like is this
animal or speed you know he's completely
the opposite so it you know he mentioned
the word zen quite a lot it's something
that you know some kind of it seems like
he's meditating when he's playing in
some special place uh so there's
something going on there you know that
keeps him calm in these chaotic
situations I'd love to bottle whatever
he's got and uh you know take take a go
at it myself I don't think I ever will
me neither and I think I could use it
but uh you know he did say he's excited
to face off against Magnus Carlson that
would be a couple of matches away if it
is indeed going to happen but speaking
of Magnus the world number one player
he's coming up right now he takes on
Eric Hansen the chess bruh celebrity and
then we also have Min against Arjun
eragacy now that's not a matchup to be
overlooked some when you initially asked
me about my favorite opening round
matchup Min and Arjun I feel like that
is going to be a close one
yes definitely I mean uh Ming is the the
quicker player I think we know that
already but Arjun is just a brilliant
player you know he's the stronger player
in classical chess so we've seen this
before though and it does seem like
speed is more important so I I would
probably say that Ming is the favorite
in that one uh but you never know if
Arjun can keep up on the clock he he
might well uh Dominate and win that one
so I yeah it's it's a hard one to note
that one Robert what's gonna happen
there yeah I think we also yeah so I was
gonna say I know what you're probably
thinking that all eyes want to be on
Magnus Carlson right like he's the
number one player in the world his first
time in the bullet Chess Championship we
just have to be honest sometimes
yeah 100 I mean like you know Magnus
against anyone I mean I've just been
commentating over the champions tour and
uh he's just destroying everyone there I
mean it is now good at chess and um I
know I think the chess bras are on tour
as well so they they are in Barcelona at
this moment in time so they're enjoying
themselves a bit as well I think I think
when you're playing Magnus and you're on
tour you've got to try and enjoy it I
might even crack open a beer Robert you
know I just think look this guy's really
good I'm just gonna enjoy myself here
and enjoy the moment but you never know
Eric's a talented player if he gets a
couple of wings on the board he could
scare Magnus a little bit right
yeah and you know speaking of cracking
open beers do that that's something that
Eric would do on stream so I will see
what kind of fighting mood he's in it
will be a tough battle but somebody
who's always ready to play especially in
these bullet time controls is min lay
he's a popular streamer he's from
Vietnam uh he Twirls his hair a lot
that's something that's common in the
chess Community assignment we've seen
that you know for decades now when
players are stressed when they're in the
heat of battle they're twirling their
hair but don't be fooled men lay I mean
he can really battle with the best of
them and I think we've got some new
information I thought this might be the
case but I didn't want to see it I was
actually speaking to Magnus over in
Norway a couple of days ago very briefly
and he mentioned he might be going over
to Barcelona and you know he's in
Barcelona as well Eric so even though
you know they're playing apparently from
opposite sides of the world they might
even be in the same room Robert so maybe
Magnus and Eric can have a beer together
while they play so they're they're good
buddies uh Eric and Magnus and uh you
know they're doing so many good things
to popularize chess I think
um just recently Magnus was playing
bullet Chess at a rave which was really
quite cool but playing in the same room
Robert I mean as long as they don't look
over each other's shoulders it should be
okay
yeah they can Trash Talk each other from
the next room you mentioned the Rave
that was really cool to see and
something that Min does I've seen this
happen on his stream he is a streamer do
follow his Channel right now uh come on
it's worth it and men will sometimes do
karaoke while playing chess I've seen
that before he likes to sing and I have
to say that artwork behind Min like I
kind of want that that looked pretty
nice so uh minlay super kind human being
but don't be fooled by that kind-hearted
personality he is Devious in the bullet
board
yeah I I can imagine is I mean he's so
quick and so dangerous and uh
um a brilliant brilliant player as well
so that that match we have to keep a bit
of an eye on but we've got to see Magnus
and Eric and are they sharing the same
Zoom call you know maybe they don't need
to have two calls they could just sit
next to each other and uh you know play
play play there so are they in the same
room I think they are we'll get more
information on that but shortly for the
first time we're gonna see Magnus Carson
playing in the bullet
championships are you excited
I'm pumped and I think it's so funny if
they are playing in the same uh house
because if one of them wants to resign
they could just stall and then we might
see them in the background of the other
players camera you know just giving them
a nice little pat on the back but that
that's it'll be funny it will it kind of
looks like they're in the same place do
you know what I would do Robert I would
maybe just pretend to fall over sneak
under the table and pull out their
bloody count power chord oh
maybe the only way to take down Magnus
take his power chord down Eric cut the
power chord
um if that's possible I expect they're
on Denver's but you can see from their
backdrop very shortly they could be in
the same building
I definitely think that they are in the
same place like I'm looking at as you're
saying the background uh this looks like
they are in the same home and you have a
great point that Eric should cut out the
power you know only when it's magnus's
turn so like if Eric's in the room with
the circuit just turn that off once you
make your move and then hey Magnus might
lose on time
I think it's the ways to you know take
Magnus down either pull magnus's power
chord will try to get some shots flowing
maybe a couple of beers you know it's
going to be tough for Eric but you never
know I mean Magnus is on great form at
the moment he's been playing very very
strong chess we don't know what Eric's
form is like but I've also seen Eric he
can he can really when he gets in the
zone he can defeat anyone you know he's
a real natural Talent he's a very fast
with a mouse as well and uh if he wins
the first couple of games
could it be a surprise
it will be a big surprise but you never
know it's bullet chess after all
you mentioned the streak that magnets
have been on nine out of nine in the
grand Chester over the board Blitz just
won the aim chess rapid event in the
Champions chess tour it feels like he's
winning everything that he plays in in
quicker time controls maybe not so much
classical Chess at least in recent
months but still so many successes to
his name and one of the four players
that we haven't talked about is origin
aragaisy speaking of somebody who's a
speed demon a junior speed chess
champion in the past somebody who has
really proven himself in a variety of
formats Arjun aragaisi is is someone we
haven't discussed in full length but he
is somebody who can take down most the
players in the competition I don't say
all of them because akaro Magnuson Reza
they may be Untouchable to players that
aren't named tang and neraditski as well
but I just feel like origin is somebody
we need to watch out for
totally agree Robert he has been tipped
has been a future world champion by many
strong players and he's one of those
players in that club maybe a future
world champion so don't write him off
he's a very strong player great
understanding of the game but we're
nearly there we're nearly ready for
kickoff right I'm excited about this one
come on let's get it on anyone else
excited
I think everybody's excited and I want
to hear from the chat who are you
rooting for in the matchup between
Magnus and Eric Hansen because there are
many chess bra fans out there so even
though Magnus the stronger player number
one player in the planet strong against
anybody he plays I think there will be a
lot of Eric fans in the chat
I think so Eric's got a great fan club
there I do want to hear who you're
cheering for in the chat there you go
there's a lot of Eric fans
a lot of Magnus fans as well they just
all they've just got a lot of fans
haven't they
as soon as that these two and we're off
we're off with some chess here we go
yes we are and so we see our two board
view on the right side Min and origin
aragosi I think that match might be
close and on the left side we have
Magnus and Eric and for the Magnus fans
out there they don't want the match to
be close they want to see Magnus dumb it
as he has been doing
yeah I mean uh it's Magnus with white
pieces obviously the pace is very very
quick from both players maybe some of
the quickest we've seen Robert I mean
they they're both 45 seconds and they're
right deep into the middle game I'd say
that Magnus has a slight advantage in
the position you see because he's got
this lovely Central Square that his
Queen is sitting on and um this Square
could be deadly later on but Eric
getting counter play now
now Eric's doing this perfectly but that
Bishop Anna fate Simon we saw in an
earlier match just a bad piece compared
to the Knight on D2 which will reroute
to the light squares so I like Max's
position Eric seemed a little upset at
himself there and by the way the chat
they've made predictions they said 43 of
them said that Eric would score under
three points 44 said three to five
twelve percent thinks he'll score five
or more points five is a lot to ask for
against Magnus
I'd I'd be happy getting that half point
I would uh hold on to that for the rest
of my life in bullet chess
um I mean we can see now Magnus moving
his Rook all the way down to the end
getting a dangerous back rank there but
more pieces getting exchanged
the problem with Black's position here
uh I would say Robert is the bishop look
at Black's Bishop Eric's Bishop is like
a big Pawn it's trapped in by the two
Central pawns and White's night
beautiful in the middle of the board and
just positionally speaking even though
Magnus is only one Pawn up well there he
goes two pawns up
that Bishop just can't do anything so
the first game seems to be going
magnus's way the bishop was bad the
clock management was a problem that C7
Pawn that's nearly queening is an issue
Magnus too fast too strong gets game one
and we see on the right hand side of our
screen it looks like Min he's about to
take game one opposite colored Bishops
do not necessarily mean to draw
especially if you have split past pawns
as you just did now he's up a queen and
he's enough time origin resigns Min
takes game one
yeah that's um okay well they're both
off and I suppose the the Magnus game
going the way we had fought and now he's
playing the perk opening and lots of
pieces getting exchanged there and that
is generally good news for black uh to
equalize the position Eric really needs
to get going at the start of this match
and uh actually now he's generated some
pressure here I wouldn't have swapped
Queens against Magnus try to keep the
Queens on against this guy he's so good
for the Queens off the board
um and how how do you think they're
gonna commiserate or celebrate
afterwards uh Robert you know as they're
in the same room do you think they might
have a shandy afterwards I think
celebrate is definitely what they'll be
doing no matter well if Magnus loses
they don't think they'll be celebrating
but I don't think Magnus is going to
lose so I think they will be celebrating
and I I don't think we want to talk
about how they're going to be
celebrating but they might live stream
it so there is that oh wow that'd be
awesome to see as well uh I think it's
probably better for those seven
vibrations that Magnus wins because he's
supposed to win and if Eric does pull
off a big upset I don't know is the
party going to be as good I'm not sure
so um yeah you know we've got to think
about these social things
before you party
black seems to be doing quite well here
in in the game again I'm looking at the
game between Eric and Magnus Robert I
mean nice last move there
look at that King I mean the king is on
D4 with a pass Pawn in front of it and
this is a good lesson use your King as a
weapon in the end game it doesn't need
to be defended it's not going to get
checkmated so I like the way that Magnus
is handling this he's forcing the white
king back and if oh Knight to C4 coming
that is going to be a win for Magnus
very good move there the the backwards
night moves are said to be some of the
hardest moves to spot and uh look at
that Big D Pawn okay he's lost the pawn
now but after an exchange on D2
Magnus goes into a winning King and pawn
ending two extra pawns and it's two nil
the Magnus already Eric giving a little
smile there they can obviously hear each
other I'd love to know what they're
saying anyone who's a lip reader in our
audience can you please tell us what do
we think they're saying to each other
Robert what do you reckon Eric said
Magnus there was it something we can
repeat on air or maybe
um I think it probably had the word
buddy in it because that is a common
Canadian word especially from Eric but
yeah I'm guessing they're just having a
little fun chatting with one another uh
but look at this game I think this is
Eric's I see the eval bar but I'm
looking at the clock like Eric is well
ahead in the clock but his Knight is
trapped oh my gosh what a recognition by
Magnus oh and it's still trout
unbelievable I mean uh how do you how do
you even be how can you beat Magnus I
mean it's just so so hard
and uh also we should just talk about
the score in the other match as well I
mean at the moment
going really against Arjun but Arjun is
attacking in the current position he's
got pressure against Black's King his
Queen coming in this would be a great
chance to get at least a point on the
board for Arjun yeah so we will go back
to our two board View and we see that
Argent gone for the attack I mean those
weak dark squares in front of the black
king the opening of the H file both
could be a problem but you know that man
is retake with the F7 Pawn on G6 he
wants to open the seventh rank so that
his King feels defended and great play
by Min he is already up three nil and we
just saw a Magnus do his job and that
game over there he's up three nil as
well but look at this
the force mate for men
yeah he's turned it around I mean it
looked a bit uh suspicious his position
but you know he brilliant chest to come
straight back in and get another point
on the board and he's looking very
strongly at the moment
um Magnus and Eric I mean they're
whitewashers so far I mean complete
white washers come on Eric and Arjun
let's see some points on the board
I think the lower seeds the players who
are the underdog have struggled mightily
to score points we've seen that in all
matches the closest was actually David
paravian 11 half five now we did get a
score correction uh that the game went
down his way not David so it was still a
six point margin but Simon looking at
these matches I think we might be
talking about eight point margins
because the high rated bullet players
are running away with it
yeah it looks that way but you do say
that I think this is Eric's best chance
so far if you look at Eric's position
he's got to be a little bit careful
about magnus's pawns but I do like his
Bishop better than the Knight I I again
I say that and he has to give it up for
the night
maybe he could get a draw out this this
should be this should be a draw right
Simon look at the clock Eric has no
chance of making a draw here he's down
14 seconds
maybe Magnus will fall sorry for him
yeah that that is one way to make a draw
but I don't think Magnus feels sorry for
anyone no no you can't I mean it's
bullet chess you it's a competition
you've got to use all your assets
including the clock and now we actually
get a position where Magnus is a pawn up
as well so it could be four nil in that
match
no chance that Magnus was gonna do that
he wins again but on the other board it
looks like Arjuna Regice he has given
his opponent midlay a queen but black is
the one delivering Checkmate that was an
incredible sequence white has a queen
but no hope because the King on F1 is
being obliterated by the Rooks of the
night
that's beautiful absolutely beautiful
finish there and that shows the talent
of Arjun he and oh yeah brilliant
tactics into the game he's gonna need to
do more than that and at least he
stopped the rot and that is important
stop the rods yes
yeah sorry go ahead Simon I was just
wondering how you can stop the Magnus
rot though I mean is that possible
it looks like this position is great for
Eric I mean the eval bar saying black is
much better but it looks not very clear
to me is Eric just up a pawn and that's
that
yeah I think so I mean he seems to have
good Rooks in the center he's got that
extra Pawn uh the Black Knight seems
good the black Bishop so it does again
seem like a good chance for Eric to at
least get half a point but why not a
whole point here is that a second Pawn
you can grab now
he has he's grabbed a second Pawn
and the key to beating Magnus I wouldn't
know from experience from what I've seen
is not taking your foot off the
proverbial gas pedal just keep going
keep playing don't spend too much time
because look at this Simon all of a
sudden I'm looking to clock oh gosh Eric
is down now six seconds and there's a
pin on the last rank that looks deeply
unpleasant Rook takes a fate with Bishop
B4 was in the air as well
it's so tricky isn't it to play against
Magnus because he just spots every
possibility and now Magnus has won a
piece as well come on Eric we just want
you to get a point I'll take half a
point Eric just get half a point on the
board but I don't think it's gonna be
this game no no takes a five just
removing the guard take G4 g7s hanging
H4 as well so it's four sequence we'll
look at Magnus he's giving up his pieces
as long as he keeps his Rook on the
board he will win this game on time
sadistic
maybe you have to be sadistic to be the
best player of all time
oh yeah it's got the drawer
and Eric Hansen scores his first half
point and we just saw someone walk
towards Eric and bring him some juice
and then I thought I saw that same
person in the mirror behind Magnus so
they really might be like in the same
room or across the hall from each other
I think they can hear each other I you
know I've never seen this before where
the two players play you know playing
can actually hear each other they can
hear the pain of the opposition But Eric
has got the draw and I think you can see
that Magnus was quite annoyed by that
because I think he wanted to get the The
Sweep you know he wanted to win every
single game and that's not possible
anymore so I think Eric can hold his
head high now
yeah it might still be a very lopsided
match when it ends and right now
actually Magnus is up in exchange but
his King is in some danger Magnus the
black pieces here but I don't see The
Knockout and if that's the case then the
material should speak volumes
yeah I like what Eric's doing though oh
he can take the Knight and take on G6
can he with a drawer at least so yeah I
mean just take the Knight oh he hasn't
gone for it wow
and there was a chance there for Eric to
get another draw by just going straight
for the black king but instead he allows
black strong Knight to remain on the
board and the black king looks very
exposed but I don't think White's gotten
enough pieces attacking you nope then
after Rook FDA we started looking Eric's
face that was the look of frustration of
playing Magnus Carlson Magnus takes
another point so he is sailing through
in this Opening match it's great play
from Magnus I mean yes there might have
been a draw but I think that's the
operative word Simon I didn't see the
exact Perpetual if black didn't take
that Bishop on G6 and so Eric probably
looked at like I should have it but I
don't see the finish line and that's why
he tried to play a move and it didn't
work out
yeah it was quite a natural move he
played but again Magnus had it well
covered as always and now we see Magnus
attacking on the king side and I like
the way he's mixing up different styles
people maybe some people assume a bit
wrongly that Magnus is just the kind of
positional player loves the ending
because that's kind of what he's famous
for but I tell you what when Magnus
attacks he's also one of the best
players in the world at attacking well
you say attack he says how badly do you
want this attack Rook H3 is about to
deliver mate on h8 and oh Queen h8 takes
G7 is the big threat oh and uh oh look
at that a lovely tactic spotted by
Magnus just making sure the black king
is trapped and this move was the
important thing at the end that was a
difficult combination to see there
Robert and he spots it straight away
difficult for us maybe but not for the
Superhuman Magnus Carlson and he's down
a piece right now so he's trying to
figure out how do I actually end this
game and this doesn't appear to be the
right way but you've said this all day
Simon the evaluation bar get go away who
cares this is gonna should be a win for
white
I think so I mean again the evaluation
bar as you say is
oh he's blundered a mating one the world
champion
not the world champion but the strongest
player in the world Falls from eight in
one oh my gosh we both said the wrong
thing there I was like oh Magnus yo he's
got this one and you know he just
allowed a Checkmate on G2 he laughs it
off but Simon we've covered enough of
magnets we know him he's probably pretty
upset about that
he's crying a little bit inside I think
there uh but maybe someone's gonna hand
him a drink now maybe a special drink I
don't know whatever whatever drink Eric
got there he did the job give that man
more of those drinks is all I'm thinking
yeah normally I'm not thinking that but
in this case I think that uh yeah he
could uh use another one to help him
score more points and Magnus he just
steals upon on C3 we've seen magnets
with the Knight against the bishop a
couple times in this match already but
when you're up a few pawns you're just
happy to have any type of position
yeah definitely he is uh coordinating
that rook and Knight so well here and
there's no way you can stop that pawn
and you know what is stronger than the
world champion an Angry World Champion
what's he got there look at that he's
having a Sit that does what is that
drink I'm intrigued Robert that looks a
bit juicy to me and Eric's got one as
well I want to be in that room yeah what
is that
I couldn't really tell it looks you know
orange so I couldn't tell if it was like
a mimosa but it wasn't a mimosa glass so
yeah I'm gonna have to
check out when they uh bring it up again
but we have another match going on of
course Magnus Carlson is always
expectable that people want to watch but
minlay you know he is taking on our
generic icy the winner of that match
will take on Magnus Carlson yes Eric has
some outside shot of winning this match
but if we're being realistic Magnus is
almost certainly going to sail through
so I am curious and will he indeed be
facing men because Min is the high rated
player in the other match and jumped out
to a lead
yes and uh yeah Ming is a dangerous
player I mean his speed his talent is
incredibly you know uh naturally
talented and he's got lots of experience
of the online format as well so uh it
looks in that match like we say that
that Ming is dominated dominating at the
moment uh I'm just intrigued we we know
what hopefully we're going to get into
that that is definitely on the interview
list of questions what are you guys
drinking I am jealous and uh we're gonna
see who it favors more of I guess that
drink Robert
yes well I think uh Magnus you know he's
gonna be happily sipping on that and
keep himself refreshed but look at the
score in this match on the right hand
side five for men three for Arjun I'm
pretty sure it was five to one and now
Arjun with the black pieces wait what
just happened what was that we just it
blundered his Queen he Mouse slipped ah
no
he was that was a great chance to bring
the deficit to one point and they just
blundered his Queen but as you say
Robert he is fighting back and I know
it's a three-point difference but
there's 13 minutes to go if you get some
roller wins you can still do this you
can still win this match
he was on a roll of wins that's the sad
part it is a win by two for those of you
who are just joining we keep reminding
you you need to win the matches by two
points and so for our generic geiste he
used that to cut that deficit to just
one game and to Mouse slip with 20 plus
seconds on your clock Simon that can be
backbreaking
yeah yes it's horrible and you've got to
try to get over that very very quickly
and Audrey must be seeing the camera
he's another player who comes across as
being very relaxed but maybe it's not so
I I think the challenge for Magnus and
Eric should be can they finish the drink
while playing a game of bullet and win
can can Magnus do that quite possibly
because you know we've got to make
things a little bit more difficult for
him I feel because he is just too too
strong
um well the position on the board is is
a pointer
sorry I saw a brilliant move from Min
late to win that game he sacked his
Queen for Rook to win another I saw the
two exclamation points and that's why I
stopped but now Min it seems like he is
trying to be a runaway train and for the
match that you you know you correctly
focused on Eric Hanson with the white
pieces here
he's winning
he is winning the black king is very
exposed the white Rooks are coming into
the position and white is a pawn up can
he put the ball into the back of the net
though makes his King safe and just
playing a little move on the side he's
also got enough time here
um
and Magnus looking a little bit annoyed
the way he's playing at the moment
yes it should be a win for one look at
them with F5 he needs to get a second
Rook to E6 but watch out for the white
king suddenly their Queen D6 check and
where's that King going
oh gosh
oh dear
it's turning again oh oh that's a nice
tactic though getting the two Rooks or
the queen
and blank white laws has a draw here is
he gonna take the draw
he's got to try to win this one surely
and he is
yes and he is down on time that's the
problem for Eric so he has that draw
pretty much at any time he wants it
until the black queen goes to D2 like it
is now because you can't oh no
look at Magnus cracker have another I
have another sippy a drink there
oh I think we were both thinking there's
no way you can lose this and then it was
Checkmate and he loses it commentators
curse there Robert
and it is karma in a way because
remember Magnus blunder that Checkmate
on G2 Queen takes G2 a few games ago uh
but for Eric you know he needed that
game desperately he seemed actually hurt
like his soul felt that pain and Magnus
is just having the time of his life
yeah yeah I think he enjoyed that one
right uh I mean do you prefer Robert
when you win a nice sort of gradual
positional game or a complete Swindle
what gives you the more satisfaction
oh I mean in bullet definitely A Swindle
because it just feels so good to be on
the cusp of defeat and then to sort of
laugh that off and just win a game and
your opponent you know is frustrated so
if you're playing a match that gives you
the upper hand but yeah I think that
both these players are not too upset
because they're drinking whatever that
delicious drink is
agree with that one
and the match score eight and a half to
one and a half for Magnus and in the
other match Arjun unfortunately is on a
bad roll here right it looked like he
was getting back into it but it's funny
how one little slip and he did I think
it was a mouse slip to blunder his Queen
you get dejected and look at that that
is just a blunder of a piece Arjun just
giving away a whole piece there and it's
looking very bad for him as well now
yeah and Min is so strong last year he
lost to dania and ended up in fourth
place but he was neck and neck it was a
tied match and been blundered and
allowed a Checkmate and that's how Donya
was able to barely uh squeak by him and
make it to the top three so Min he's
been here before he wants to win this
and guess what you know what his reward
is Simon if he wins this match he gets
to play Magnus Carlson and you know as a
grand master who doesn't get invitations
to all the biggest events he wants that
opportunity even if it's in bullet chess
yeah agreed I mean even though you're
probably likely to lose that match and
you realize that just the opportunity of
playing the best player in the world is
very very special and you never know you
know if things go your way and Ming is
capable of doing well against Magnus you
might cause a major upset it's it's
certainly more fun I think being the
underdog in these matches
going back to the games the score line
is pretty similar in both both matches I
mean uh Robert really I mean uh both
Magnus and Ming are dominating at the
moment oh Min just delivered a Checkmate
as soon as you're dominating it looked
like it was going to be a trade of
Bishops but he checkmates origin
aragaisy and unfortunately for origin it
just isn't his match once that Queen
slipped happened it was five to three at
that point now it's nine to three so Min
says I don't care how I get the job done
you asked do you prefer to get a Swindle
win Min says I don't care as long as I
keep winning
yeah a win is a win especially in bullet
yes and
um well again Eric in trouble in that
one and he loses and I want a bit of
shake of the head uh there's seven just
about seven eight minutes to go
we're seeing this opening a lot the
grinfeld
um
problem with the grunfeld as soon as you
lose as black that dark Square Bishop
which you can see black has done
protecting your king your king is always
a little bit weak and that could be an
issue for Eric here the the black king
doesn't have much protecting it
magnusing Magnus targeting the other
side of the board as well now and look
at the holes in the position the Black
Knight is about to go to C6 and then D4
the White Knight would love to go to D5
at some point so White's King feels very
safe because of this Pawn structure look
at this G2 F3 E4 G4 it's a weird
structure the dark squares may seem a
bit vulnerable but black as Wesley does
not the Firepower and he goes back when
he should have went forward I guess
yeah there was one chance there I think
for Eric and uh now again I prefer to be
white here that pawn just coming
straight through the middle of the board
and another one joining it there
in a position
this is messy the black king looks
exposed but that pawn on D2 is super
strong and Magnus he's like what did I
just do because he can't play F6 the
queen was loose in E5 he's gonna win the
D2 ball
yeah and he lost he lost his strongest
Pawn there and uh
Eric oh laundering there I think
because now somehow I mean whatever
whatever Magnus does yeah even when he
blunders he seems to win I mean it's
just incredible yeah
I'm looking at Eric's clock and down to
10 seconds against Magnus 18 no chance
for Hanson he's a king F6 G5 check is
gonna happen always do this and the pawn
just runs off the board
yeah
yeah four seconds is not enough and I
try and remember did Eric actually win a
game or was it just draws
yes sorry yeah you mentioned that a
second okay what is that drink let's
look what is that
I reckon that is like some kind of
orange juice a peanut kind of pina
colada it can't be of orange juice
um but it looks so nice yeah
whatever it was I want one do you reckon
they've hired in a special cocktail
waiter just for the match I mean that
would be quality you know let's get a
cocktail maker just for our match
that would be excellent maybe you know
one of their friends that they're on
this trip with just happens to be an
expert mixologist I mean I'm whatever is
happening there I want in on it because
first of all Barcelona sounds lovely no
matter the time of year uh whatever
they're having I would like some oh gosh
Eric does not want to have any part of
that skewer on the diagonal he's on E5
back rank Rook D1 take B1
um
oh dear it's all gone a bit wrong and uh
there goes
oh he doesn't even want the bishop
straight away he's doing it much
cleverly attacking The Rook and another
piece is dropping there you can see that
Eric's
a bit upset with the way things are
going
and we're hearing a bit more information
and apparently the the cocktail Mark the
maker is Eric's brother Dylan so who is
very good at making cocktails so we're
hearing that first hand
and uh again make sure you check out the
chess bras they are on or around Europe
at the moment to
you spot them you might even better
get a game against her I'm just curious
if it's an actual brother or because
they're bras are they like Bros in that
way like I feel like it's probably not
his actual biological brother not to say
that those kind oh it is over being told
it is
sorry Dylan my apologies
I just assumed you know they're bras so
and they got that going but
wow it got a lot it got a lot of bra
friends haven't they there's a lot of
brawls out there chess bras
yeah they really are they're on a tour
right now so I mean you can follow their
schedule I don't know it off the top of
my head but they are they were in London
I believe now in Spain so they're
meeting with many chess fans
yeah good thing to do and one of the
great things about modern chess you can
stream your activities as you go around
and again looking at the positions you
can see that this is Magnus attacking I
love it when we see manners attacking so
we don't always get it as a check mate
must be come out Black's King has too
many pieces hovering around it the magic
number when attacking is normally three
pieces and white has those three pieces
the queen is ready to dive in one square
fours will be checked mate you can't
defend that with a bishop because white
can just take the bishop due to the pin
and uh I can't see any way to defend
that there Robert Magnus winning another
game
yeah do you see that feature chat death
taxes and Magnus winning at chess that
that seems fair Magnus just does it all
the time and 13 and a half to one half
so Eric knew that this was going to be a
tough one he knew he was going to lose
the match but do you think he believed
to get more than one half points against
Magnus
I I reckon he you've got to believe that
haven't you otherwise why are you there
you've got to believe that you're gonna
score okay you know there's no point
going into the match thinking I'm going
to lose every game I mean Eric's not
that kind of guy you know Eric's a great
player and on his day when things go
right he can he can score more points
um now the position here I mean I'd love
to see another win from Eric this is a
good chance right he seems to be doing
okay Magnus sacrificed The Exchange but
it looks a bit dubious to me Robert
uh yeah because two exchanges I was
trying to quickly count what's the
material it is two minor pieces for two
Rooks but his Knight is coming to D5 and
maybe into E3 and C3 those kind of
annoying squares and look at the
evaluation how does Magnus do this right
it still looks problematic for black oh
D hangers oh he just drops his roof
oh no
oh
wow okay that I mean how does Magnus do
it Robert you you were saying I don't
know how does he do it I just watched it
happen and I still can't answer the
question and oh yeah Magnus normally he
laughs when something like that happens
I think he's starting to feel a little
bit bad
well there's only a minute 24 left and
they can get to the serious activity of
more cocktails and enjoying the
nightlife in Barcelona which I'm sure
they're both looking forward to doing
very shortly but a very powerful
performance from Magnuson just to remind
everyone is double elimination so Eric
will have another chance which is great
and Magnus will be progressing to the
next round and he's gonna be playing uh
the winner and the winner seems to be
decided in the other match
to minlay is so strong if he weren't
alongside the match of Magnus Carlsen we
would have definitely been focusing on
his games against Argent era geisi Arjun
error guys he's a super Grandmaster one
of the biggest prodigies on the planet
signed a huge sponsorship deal uh that
was worth I believe over one million
dollars I think it was 1.5 if I'm
remembering correctly and we know that
he is a superstar not just in the making
he's currently a superstar but look at
Mingo Bishop A2 check he wants to
deliver a Checkmate against that King
and he's looking for it he wants to find
it and will he is the question it looks
like the answer might be no
yep
um not long to go now
just have to reboot sign quickly oh good
Min just want to reboot his brain
because he walked into a checkmates and
he laughed about it but looks like
Magnus up
25 seconds against Eric in their final
game probably going to win that one as
well and Min he wants to win every game
he plays but he's down the pawn against
Arjun in their final game
so we're looking uh at these two matches
it's been decided Magnus Carlson huge
winner over Eric Hansen and Min Lei
winning by six points right now but he
might lose this final game as well to
make it a five-point margin he did just
drop a piece there so Min versus Magnus
will be the case but Arjun yeah Arjun
will probably make his presence felt in
the losers bracket so Simon I mean
Magnus doing Magnus things it looks like
Arjun lost his uh connection there
unfortunately we would love to get him
back but clever Noir MK Min is having a
wonderful time yes indeed so Simon last
game here between Magnus and Eric
yeah it's um you know great play from
Magnus and you know great play all round
I mean like it's great to see them also
just enjoying that drink do you think
we're gonna be able to get into you with
one of them
oh I maybe both at the same time while
they're making new drinks I feel like
that's commonplace for the chess bra
scene but right now I think that Eric
wants to forget about this match and I
know a way he can forget about it thanks
Simon we can think of a few ways so he
is memory will be short term
oh
yeah
yeah you gotta get on with it and we see
in this matchup card Magnus Carlson he
wins against air cans I think that final
score was even higher than that but you
know 16 and a half one half was the
final and Min wins 11-6 so a great
result for him I think he's probably
even gonna be disappointed and that's
what happens when you're one of the best
bullet players on the planet so we know
the matchup in the next round will be
Magnus versus Min we will try to bring
in at least one of these players for an
interview hopefully we can get Magnus
and maybe Eric by his side as they drink
cocktails and enjoy the Spanish scene
but for now we're gonna go to Quick
break we'll bring Simon back and and
interviewee so stay where you are this
is the bullet just Championship we'll be
right back in just a few
foreign
it's Danny here and as you may know
chess.com and chessable are now one and
I'm here to show you how you can make
your chest.com and chessable one in just
a few clicks to start let's log in and
connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we return with both participants in
the match-up Magnus gonna have to start
with you first of all congrats and my
first question for you is is it
Bittersweet to defeat your friend or do
you relish the opportunity to take down
people you're close to
now my only uh regret was that I was
hoping to to get a clean tweet
that didn't happen no
um
yeah uh no I it's
um it's uh it's fine one of us had to to
go through and I'm happy that it's me
and the burning question that we had
here hi guys uh if you're doing all
right is what was the cocktail
I don't know you'll have to
um you'll have to ask some of the other
members of the chessbra community
community
yeah okay we I think we need
clarification on this
can we get clarification obviously as a
a non-alcoholic orange juice or
something probably yeah obviously it's
um
it looked delicious that's what we were
talking about it throughout a lot of the
broadcasts but uh Eric you know question
for you you've been on tour now you've
been you know maybe away from playing so
much bullet chess was it you know just
thrown back into the lions for you or
have you been doing something behind the
scenes to prepare for players like
Magnus and bullet
um no originally the terminal scheduled
like a week or a week and a half from
now so I knew I'd have a bit of a buffer
to try to like go home play some bullet
trying to get back into it but the way
it was scheduled you know didn't sleep
last night just got here on playing and
we have a pretty big crew we're having
we're having a good time but I'm I
haven't been on the computer on
chess.com
anything uh much this week so I was just
hoping to
sometimes when you're a little rusty you
don't think as hard and you can play
intuitively but it didn't really click
for me today it was just straight from
the airport to the hotel and
um definitely tough to balance
it seems like you've both been pretty
busy recently right
um I mean Eric you've been touring
around Europe and uh Magnus you've been
playing quite a lot of Chess and raving
at the same time
uh you've still got lots of energy at
the moment
no I actually
um
um I got in an earlier an hour earlier
than uh
then Eric and the boys so I had a little
more time to get a nap before playing so
that helped a bit
but I think the um the energy will come
by by being here in Spain
maggots you're playing Min tomorrow in
the next matchup how do you feel about
that I mean Min obviously is very strong
ball player
yeah it depends when when is the
tournament because I was hoping to catch
the um
I was hoping to catch the chess bra
viewer tournament uh live tomorrow as
well and I I heard I mean these are
rumors but I heard there are other
participants from
the bullet championship
not only Eric who might be participating
in this in this tournament so um I'm
hoping to you know to get be able to do
both uh seriously though I think Min is
um
he's a very strong
player really really fast in scramble uh
also has a good
uh positional feeling really resourceful
so um he's a tough moment
and Eric uh how's your energy levels
because you've been on the tour for a
while now
um you're feeling like you've got good
energy Eric
um
I got rejected to Brookline every day
this weekend
Oh no I
would say that for another time but I
need I need I need the sun to give me
some energy for sure it was uh Berlin
was an interesting weekend but uh I
don't think I saved enough juice to the
bowling okay I mean I was I was just
expecting to do a bit better I mean
Magnus has been playing really well
recently anyways online and uh
um you know uh bullets one of those
games you have to put a lot of time in
or at least get into the form it's not
something you can just just jump into
the pool and then expect to have those
instincts ready so
um yeah open open uh obviously to do
better next time but uh we are into it
right now hosting some events so kind of
uh in a different headspace than than
ideal but I love playing bullet and then
even having a chance to play in like a
really strong event with all the top
players like this is still uh still good
and they're still loses bracket so um
uh after after today's uh results
hopefully that wakes me up a little bit
and I can get some practice and uh
before the next match so
yeah that's uh
that's uh at least losing the Magnus is
kind of expected there's there's you
know there's there's some beautiful
players in the field but
um
I definitely I thought my back was
against the wall uh right at the start
today
yeah I think that's fair Eric and of
course you got another match tomorrow in
the losers bracket and Magnus I mean big
picture here it's your first time
playing in the bullet Chess Championship
everyone's excited about it Ali Reza was
excited about it everyone's you know
just been talking it's great to play you
how do you feel about being in the
bullet Chess Championship having a swing
at Hikaru alireza Tang near ditski and
everybody else
no I I spoke about it a little bit a few
days ago but I think I'm a little bit
too slow uh if I was playing from from
home and I was in good shape I think uh
I have I would have a good chance but uh
right now I feel like I'm probably
pretty pretty significant Underdog
against uh Hikaru and others but we'll
see
I'm sure after a couple of nights out
you will get your energy and you know
maybe a new mouse and things will things
will just flow
sorry and Eric you've got to do better
get into those clubs in Berlin but let's
chat for another day yeah you didn't
count this time and I was Zero I was uh
struggled this weekend and with you we
also didn't uh so I'm not sure what
accessories that but it's definitely not
more chess players that's for sure
I didn't I didn't really help last time
either so uh anyway have a good time
yeah
we don't want to keep you any longer
guys have a great one
well that was Magnus and Eric both
together having a good time despite the
fact that they had to face off and there
could only be one winner but we see that
Magnus moves on to play against Min uh
Min was great against our generic icy
one by five in the end and Simon I
really like the show of appreciation and
respect that Magnus has for men you know
he was talking about going out having a
good time and they will do all that but
he also was like you know this guy is
serious and he's great in time scramble
so he knows that tomorrow will be a
tough test
yeah I I think that's a really nice
thing it's a nice thing that Magnus does
often when he respects someone he will
say that and uh
um talking that way I mean that that's a
good Accolade doesn't it you know having
the best player in the world say those
things will give you a lot of confidence
and the match tomorrow you never know if
Magnus is out late and um he can't get
the right Mouse uh you know things
things that go wrong there and I thought
that was a nice nice interview that was
a fun interview anyway I think they're
Robert
yeah I think if we were off air we would
have some different questions but we'll
save those for a later time it seems
like they're you know with a film crew
with a bunch of people they'll have a
nice time of it in Spain but speaking of
nice time speaking of fun the fun does
not stop just because Magnus has already
played his match coming up right now
will be Anish Geary against jaspam Jose
Martinez and then we have Hikaru
Nakamura the top seed in the entire
bracket taking on qualifier Amin Ohan
young who's played in the junior
speeches Championship who's working his
way towards the Grand Master title he's
nearly 2 500 feet in classical chess so
Simon two excellent matchups I think
Hikaru undeniably the very heavy
favorite I would be surprised if that
one's close but let's talk about Geary
versus Martinez that one at least on
paper should be a tight battle
yeah 100 I mean you pick this match out
at the start didn't you Robert as being
uh maybe your match of the day and one
of the closest ones because uh obviously
Jose has a great track record is
incredibly quick this is his format but
then you've got a niche who is Anish
giri you know one of the strongest
classical players in the world and also
a very good bullet player uh so it could
go either way with Phil
and the chat agrees they said 51 of them
said that Jose was the favorite to win
they thought that he is going to take it
and then 49 for a niche so that is as
close as it gets besides 50 50. so in
each giri super Grand Master Tata steel
Winner Takes on this man on the screen
for you that's Jose Martinez I like the
blue curtain Simon I think that brings
nice color to the room uh for Jasper but
Jose he is a beast he's won two bullet
brawls call him a brawler he is ready
for a slugfest and he'll have that today
against Gary
100 I think that's going to be a very
interesting match and just uh that that
uh vote of 49 against 51. I think that
just shows how close everyone thinks
that match will be and it's also
obviously fantastic to have Hikaru
coming up as well we've just seen Magnus
and now we've got Hikaru I mean what
more can we want in the Chess World and
uh if you think players are fast then
wait until you watch the monster hikara
in action right I mean he's unbelievable
he really is the final boss as people
like to call him because he's always in
the last round maybe in the last man
standing throughout most of these events
but he will have a tough slate of
opposition ahead and he starts off with
Amino hanyan but I have to get back to
Geary and Jose Martinez and I think the
biggest difference between Anish and the
other super Grand Masters that are not
farrugia Magnus and akaru like the
fabianos the argeneragaisies is that
Anisha is actually really really really
good at bullet he's very fast he's
playing bullet quite regularly he's
taking a break I was just messaging with
him uh yesterday but I think for Anish
he is going to come prepared and he is
not going to back down against the
brawler that is Jose Martinez so we're
off the games are underway we'll get our
two boards seen up and I think we'll see
the moves just appear on screen very
fast
yes and they are off and the first game
is a good indication of uh just getting
a little bit of a safety net you kind of
want to win the first game it's actually
quite important you just get that little
confidence boost and um already looking
at the games a niche playing very
aggressively opening up the H file there
look at the clock by the way and he's
just playing aggressively he's also a
speed demon he's up 10 plus seconds on
Jasper and he wants queen H6 check going
for meat it doesn't pan out so instead
he's forced to just trade pieces he's
down upon so better position for Jose
but Simon I guess how do we weigh that
that's a very important question is how
do you weigh a material or a positional
advantage in exchange for a clock
advantage
is something I never get right Robert I
mean you've got to play quickly but
you've got to I mean what my mistake is
probably not realizing when the critical
moments are there and that's when you've
got to spend that extra couple of
seconds just to make sure you calculate
it well and you know going back to the
board here a niche probably still
getting into the right sort of uh Vibe
for this
um he's playing very quickly and I was
thinking his position's really bad but
maybe he has some chances here because
the black king is quite weak in this
position it's a real really interesting
position
yeah I mean jostim is down in exchange
uh oh wait excuse me yeah the down
exchange I was right I saw one of the
Rooks disappear but but they both did
for both sides and so it's going to be a
big battle there by the way Hikaru won
the first game he did a little bit of a
finger point because he forked his
opponent's king and queen and now in
game two it looks like it's all hikar
there as well but okay Anish dropped his
Rook but look at the clock Simon look at
how much more time Anish had he was able
to make a draw because of it
yeah that might be a strategy he
realizes he needs to try here that he
needs to play much quicker than he
normally does and um it'll be
interesting Anish is very famous for his
brilliant openings he's a great opening
player and on the other hand Jose has
opening systems he doesn't play a lot of
theory Jose he just wants to get a
position he can play you'd imagine
therefore that a niche has the advantage
at the start of the game and I think you
can sort of uh well is is it working
here for a niche I don't know but uh
looks fairly even though no matter what
the evaluation Bar says well it says
it's even here as well
it certainly will be I'm looking at this
clock I'm looking at the board Clark
says about even position says about even
but wow a pawn was just giving up on H6
but I guess look at the counter player
that Anisha is getting against the E4
Pawn although he took with the C5 note
so he doesn't even want that pawn Simon
he's playing around it but maybe that
was a wrong choice
yeah uh this move though very dangerous
for black here and okay finds a way out
of it and um fairly even this position
even now after the tactics have happened
and they're moving an incredible case
here at this moment in time we can just
feel this good this match is just every
point is going to count in it and didn't
win material that one but the black Rook
now getting into the position and black
is better here yeah Black's winning a
pawn it's actually two extra pawns on
the queen side compared to one extra on
the king side Joss from is the one ahead
in the club Joshua is Jose that's his uh
chess.com username and we see people
rooting for him in his featured chat but
right now it's all Anish in the position
but on the clock it's all Jose and I
think Anish is there just in time either
you go Rook H1 to stop the H Pawn or he
could bring your king back if you didn't
push it right away it's going to be at
least it should be Simon a win for a
niche just push the pawns get a queen
yeah he should have enough time here
he's got seven seconds he just needs to
finish it off and now he can pretty much
pre-move all the way he's using his King
look at the speed they're moving at
phenomenal but this is a nice strategy
you can pre-move your way to the victory
there what did I tell you that a niche
unlike some of his fellow super Grand
Masters he has the mouse speed and by
the way Hikaru Nakamura out to a two and
a half lead he is cruising of course we
will see plenty of a car throughout this
but I believe that Anish versus Jose
that is our Marquee matchup of the
opening round of the winners bracket
yeah I feel we're going to see a lot
more of Hikaru in this competition uh
it's always nice to see the way he plays
so I'm sure we get back to that one soon
but this match at the moment well maybe
a slight surprise for some people that a
niche takes the lead now and um
um Jose here getting a very solid
position
but very equal position as well at the
moment
yeah and you know we're gonna hear the
jokes about the niche making draws all
that stuff but I actually think keeping
it solid keeping it closed it can favor
the quicker player despite the fact that
he may be lower rate in classical chess
is that Jose can maneuver quicker he's
got that Mouse speed and right now it's
completely level Simon but look at Anish
trying to bring that King up his King is
first to the center
yeah King very important piece in the
ending and also white has this useful
open C5 he now comes in with the check
and he gets behind that pawn winning an
important Pawn there and um one of um
anisha's real skills is in the end game
you know there's there's him this Magnus
Carlson they're probably the two best
end game players and as soon as I say
that he drops a pawn of course and we
now go into well a drawn position are
they going to try to flag each other
here I mean you might as well if you've
got more time
F4 he gave away a pawn he just sent it
but he was trying to wait for that
pre-move Rook back to E3 so that is what
the best bullet players do is that they
know that they're not risking losing by
that decision but you can actually win
and Anish doing the same just get here
take that pawn have it but he's going
back and forth back and forth I think
Jose might be a little bit too fast
Simon
yeah but a niche is quick right as well
I didn't think a knee should be this
quick and he's got a Time Advantage now
Niche maybe he's gonna flag Jose I did
not expect this oh the quickest place
ever
they're both making bad moves in their
time travel but a niche does secure the
draw and Simon maybe you're right but I
really thought that Jose would be the
fast of the two and he might be in the
long run but he's just proved to
everybody that he can outpace his
opponent
that's right I mean that that was if you
needed proof that was proof just how
quick a niche can be uh he knows how to
pre-move he knows a lot of the tricks
he's obviously been practicing uh quite
hard and the score line at the moment
still Incredibly Close just one point in
it
yes and I think for Jose who has won a
couple bullet brawls and you think what
does that mean he's been ahead of Hikaru
of Dania Andrew tank plays in those
Magnus also joins the party so I mean
Jose has really done his work but right
now look at this position it's Anish up
a pawn ahead on the clock a niche
happens to look like a stronger the two
Bull players right now yes he's looking
very very good
um I never thought a knee should be a
bullet player I mean I don't know why I
didn't assume and you should be a bullet
player you mentioned these jokes about
Niche being a very drawish player
earlier on and I have to say I think
that's a little bit unfair on each if we
watch his games he's actually a very
aggressive player I mean he had all
draws in one candidate but apart from
that his side of Chess is is aggressive
saying that black and a niece is in
charge here Robert
yeah and he's just playing wonderfully
he's also well ahead on the board of a
piece well on the clock and you saw Jose
kind of wave it off yeah that's the
White Flag I resign a niche now up two
points so uh
Amino hanyan you know he's also playing
in this one against Hikaru Nakamura and
that might not be the spread that people
expect so let's go back to our two board
scene when we get the chance because
Nakamura is ahead Simon but look at the
score it's only a one point lead
that is not a big lead I expected this
could even be a whitewash but I mean
it's playing incredibly good chance I
mean he won again wow is it two and a
half full
that could be an amazing upset right so
okay it's a very close match anyway
going on there and we're update the
scores quickly but I mean putting in
some performance at the moment
yeah I think the so it actually is a car
who's getting those wins we did have a
misunderstanding based on the camera
sorry about that everybody but it looks
like Hikaru four and a half one half so
it was a victory at least one thus far
for amino hanyan uh that's still to his
credit but now it does seem like Hikaru
is in charge I I love that there's a
comment in the chat saying uh okay it's
all back to normal now and that's kind
of what we expect when Hikaru is playing
that that score line
um of dominating and here he has the
extra Queen Black's trying to get a
blockade into position but there's
certainly no blockade as of yet
wow and these Geary uh up against Jose
Martinez Hikaru he's in the driver's
seat against Amino honey as you
mentioned a blockade would be necessary
for amino hunting to draw this game but
I don't know I feel like I always call
him his full name now that I'm just
saying it so much I can't just say one
name it's Amino hanyan to me but let's
just call him Ohanian uh he is doing
really well Simon against Hikaru to try
to hold before
yeah he's playing very well but there
you go a couple of Pawns dropping there
he's getting strong counts played over
to Queen side pawns and the computer
actually thinks that this position is
equal this ending that Hikaru and Amina
got there and um you know he's am I
right I think it means I say only but
he's only an international Master is
that right look at the confusion on both
players faces I mean dropping The Rook
there
yes
he is an I am entitled only he's well on
his way to the GM title uh he's a
teenager he played in the junior
speeches Championship he also has at
least two GM Norms uh to his name as far
as I'm aware might already be three
that's the progress that these kids make
these days but right now Hikaru he's
bopping his head you know he's feeling
the music and he is up by four points
whereas the other match of Simon it's
very close
very close and one more thing about me
he kind of he's got a bit of Eric Hanson
about him right is he we're not sure is
he that he's connected to Eric because
he's not his long lost brother there or
something they're quite similar to me
you know
the Jose versus the niche match is so
close and I I think you can just tell by
their body language how much they are
focusing and they realize how close this
match will be
Jose with the attack here
um what's happening there's something
happening he's not sure with his hand
what's going on yeah what is happening
because Jose you know if what we have on
screen is correct it looks like he just
won the game by Checkmate yeah but he
seemed you're flustered by something
that was happening so I would love to
receive word we'll of course ask our
team they're working hard behind the
scenes to figure this out but yeah Jose
did not look pleased
no and uh this win should take the match
to free all uh you you can't get any
close than that this is the closest
match Robert you're so good at calling
matches you you called this match out of
every single match and it looks like the
one uh that is going to be the closest
maybe there's some freeze here I'm sure
we'll get on top of it very soon
whatever's happening there yeah as they
figure it out let's go back to Hikaru
and uh Ohio in here they're still oh
Rook takes a sick
oh my gosh what was that
wow what happened there did Hikaru
blunder
I mean that was a pawn capture on A6 but
the Rook was defending it so that seemed
like a terrible mistake
you literally blink and you miss all the
action it's just uh just typical and um
okay
your car was black in that game by the
way so the cameras are oh okay um but I
think you know a lot of things happening
uh with Jose and Anish as well so
um yeah that was a win for Hikaru uh he
is now up five enough one half it would
see him so while Jose and
Anish are figuring things out it seems
like there are some technical issues uh
so to be transparent with you uh we are
gonna take a quick break but when we
return you know it's going to be more
from the bull Chess Championship you
will not want to miss the conclusion of
today's action between Anish giri and
Jose Martinez and Hikaru Nakamura and
amino hanin will be back soon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
we apologize for the delay but we are
back and it looks like Hikaru Nakamura
is thriving 9f1f over Amino hanyan and
then we see that in the other matchup
Jose Martinez down on the bottom right
he leads 6-3 against Anish giri Simon if
I'm remembering correctly it was three
to one Indonesia's favor that means five
wins in a row for Jose
yeah Jose's really rolling now I mean
Anish is playing great it looked like
Nish was actually dominating a little
bit there but Jose back in the match
with double anisha's points so uh if
Anish hasn't gotta have any chances here
he's got to win this game and get a role
going himself
yeah and he's got a great position he
just won a rook so I think that's game
over Ian anisha's favor and for Jose you
don't resign remember we saw Dania doing
that earlier Simon where he would just
sip on some water take his time then
eventually lose the game Jose not
perhaps lucky the match clock 11 minutes
50 seconds left you kind of want to
waste that time
yeah that would have been certainly
better match strategy just to try to let
the pot go down when you have an
advantage on the scoreboard because the
more games you play the more chances you
give your opponent to catch up and um
and I've been watching the chess it's
been very very close between these two
as you called it Roberts uh Anish has
been playing some nice positional chess
but I would say it's been up to the task
you know he's a very quick and he
doesn't give much away in the way he
plays you know he's got a very solid
style Jose and it's very hard to break
him down and we're getting lots of these
positions lots of these kind of middle
game end game positions where Jose is
playing fantastic so uh close match
though still time left very close match
and it will serve as a good reminder
it's win by two so all the niche gear
needs to do is cut the deficit to one
point when the time elapses then you get
another chance so a two-point deficit
he's right there although Rook takes D4
that was a blunder from Anish as soon as
I was saying what he needs to get done
he is maybe not doing it
Ah that's that's a big mistake from him
because uh you know it's going to be
three points I think if you're in grass
for like two points maybe three points
with you know some time left it's okay
but as soon as it starts going out your
grip it's yeah it's downhill the
position now though still a bit messy
white has this very strong passport
yes a niche could have repeated moved
but said he's playing for a win he's
maybe realizing Simon that he is the
faster player in the time scrambles I
really can't believe I'm saying that
because of how quick Jasper is but look
at the clock suddenly a niche is up a
couple seconds
yep he's up and that is very important
at this stage but they are repeating the
position I think is that right it looks
like that one's a draw so
you know I think it's one of those
moments that Anish might regret he could
have gone for the flag uh it wasn't even
in game they both knew that it should be
a draw but there's no should bees in
bullet it's chaos you cannot control a
lot of things when you're just throwing
pieces around without even looking at
what your opponent's doing but a niche
with the black pieces here I mean look
at this position from jossum I think
that Jose should be happy about the
opening
yeah he's picked up a pawn now as well
More Strangers coming in and more
importantly he's got some very nice
squares for his Rooks here there's one
square and there's another Square that's
a killer you have to play this move but
now your king is so exposed later 64.
rookies before you can't take the Rook
back oh Rook takes F4 can you see it
he's played it
age five keeping the king closed
yes
so what is this Rook takes rook and the
queen G7 check in H7 you might get a
queen over there
maybe H7 straight away as well Robert
and he's played it same idea here just
trying to push the pawn through
that was I look at look at his face I
see it yeah we both noticed that Jose
was kind of like what was I doing but
yeah I'm getting the win
I love that he he drops a rook but he
still wins the game I feel that could
have been a key game Robert I mean
there's eight minutes and a half left
but he's taken the lead to three points
now can you come back from a three-point
lead
you can because you know we'll keep
reminding people you just need to cut it
to one it's win by two so as long as the
niche uh can make it to a one-point
deficit he has a chance but look at this
position really nice for white Bishop
pair open space but there are no clear
Targets in Black's position and that
means you're gonna struggle to find an
actual plan besides having an
aesthetically pleasing position
this is kind of how the game the match
has been going between these two I mean
a lot of time a niche is getting the
slight Advantage the two Bishops like
nice slightly nicer Pawn structure Pawn
in the middle but Jose is very solid and
he's just repeating look at the Knight
going backwards and forwards he's
basically saying to a niche right you've
got to do something how are you going to
do it and then he repeats again and he
just waits for a niche to you know do
something that he can take advantage of
and uh it's a weird style very strange
style Robert
yeah it's a kind of wriggling his way
out of tough moments and for a niche I
mean this is a type position where oh
look at that he caught him I was about
to say you might want to take on D5 and
try to catch him and he did catch him
because Jose was pre-moving
yeah and that's the danger of playing
this way you know if you pre-move all
the time uh you can easily blunder and
he's doing the right thing though now
he's making the clock drag out a little
bit he might as well
play until the last seconds of course a
niche will win this game
but I've got a nightmare check crafty
move there
that was awesome because getting a queen
doesn't change the result so you might
as well Force the niche to waste a
couple seconds getting his King out of
check
yeah I was crafty I like that every
second counts and he's running his time
down there and uh now the deficit is
only two games I think really close
Hikaru is dominating is up to 15 and a
half points that's more points that
anyone else has scored I mean the match
is not close there that's why we're
concentrating on this one because this
could come this could even be a playoff
all that Anish needs to do is win one
more game
that's right I mean Hikaru is just
cruising right now completely dominating
that matchup credit to him he's such a
beast but we're locked in on this
matchup it is very close two-point lead
for Jose Martinez and look at the clock
in this game this is what is that oh
it's not a pond blender because the
queen is on F2 but look at Jose I think
he's just looking at this match right
now Simon he wants the burn clock but he
also wants to beat Anish on the clock
he's up 10 seconds
yeah I mean again very solid position
and it's Jose you you might think a
niche will be the player trying to keep
things more solid but Jose is keeping
everything under control and just trying
not to give too much away this position
of course is equal a niche trying to get
in with this queen but it's the time now
which is important there's only five and
a half minutes left of the match
Jose's two points up
Anish just has to avoid losing this game
and then he's got to win the next one
right I mean
it's the only strategy I can suggest
here but in actual fact it's looking a
bit better for a niche now oh it's
looking much better because look at the
King on H4 King F3 would be met by Queen
G1 so he steals upon as king runs away
and if you're a niche you might even
make a draw here he's not going to
because he's up a pawn and wants to win
but you know what I mean Simon sometimes
you just allow the repetition to avoid
the loss
that's right and uh I mean it's a great
chance so I mean if he wins this one
he's got 12 seconds
can he do it in time I mean yes so far
we've seen a niche moving very quickly
but it's going to come down to the clock
keep an eye on the clock everyone kick
Queen C4 and gets a queen he's now upper
Queen and running out of checks is Jose
Martinez aniskets
brilliant play from a niche that was a
really important game Robert one point
in it with four and a half minutes to go
this is insanely close yeah Indonesia
has been proving throughout the match
that he can keep up on the clock and
that's what a lot of The Underdogs have
been unable to do so this I mean it's
the eight nine matchup for a reason they
are very very close and Jose has his
work cut out for him
yes it does and um he goes straight in
with his normal opening here more pieces
on the board and this one the Queen's
still on
fairly even at the moment uh the
valuation bar doesn't think so
maybe there was some tricks there but
this is a good strategy pushing the
h-born quite a modern way of playing
you've always got some ideas around your
opponent's king then and it's almost
blundered yeah it's blundered sorry
Robert I didn't see that he's blundered
a piece you're fine Jose didn't see it I
didn't see it I just thought the eval
bar go Sky High it's because Bishop E3
hit the Queen of the Night in a row and
now it's another piece
wow unbelievable maybe he's has he
managed to save that piece there he has
but it's still one piece a niche should
win this game and it will be equal on
points with only a couple of minutes to
go so close this match look at this E6
next it's just made like the black king
it's just completely checkmated over
there
beautiful place and there it is the
Arabian Checkmate seven and a half all
we have to stay on this match
um just a quick update Hikaru is just
dominating in the other one as Hikaru
does
I mean your car is just so good like
it's funny how we haven't even had time
to look at that match because this one's
been so close but Hikaru is running away
he ran away from the start 19 and a half
one and a half the highest score of the
day but in this one Simon it's tied up
right now Anish has the black pieces
he's the better Pawn structure but Jose
has the bishop pair can white get some
kind of attack going it doesn't really
look like it's in my eyes
it looks like a very solid wall
structure what you need to do in these
situations where things are quite static
is look for your palm break and leave
aside really has a good Pawn break right
Robert I mean white can try F4 that's
not gonna help his structure there he
goes he plays the F or break the problem
with this one is the Black Knight now
has a great Square in the center of the
board
um so if anyone's better it's going to
be a niche yet again here
I mean just excellent play from a niche
quick play but Jose still ahead on the
clock and he's keeping all the pawn
breaks under control there's Bishop
reroutes to the C6 Square will attack
the E4 Pawn you have to be very careful
Jose with a knight trying to come to C5
as well
and the pawn drops in the middle this is
a horrible run for Jose Anish is in
Turbo Drive the white king is so weak
here Black's piece is looking great the
Knight can come into the middle at some
point so white trying to get his King
safer okay it's got a bit better for him
now great maneuver there getting rid of
that night and all of a sudden White's
winning yeah the the piece on e4 drops
because the Knight F6 was removed MBL we
see you what's up Maxime saying Anish my
goat but unfortunately he lost that game
as soon as you walked into the chat so
for a niche he needs to not lose this
game if he loses the match is over if he
draws we get extra time Simon and so
Anish better have looked at the rules I
know players they don't always look at
the four man the rules but he better
have checked them out coming into the
bull Chess Championship
this is the game isn't it this is the
big one as you say Robert
um if a niche just doesn't lose this
game it will go into overtime if a niche
loses this game Jose takes the match
you've got to be two points up
um you know as you go on hello to mvl as
well and everyone else in the chat seems
like we've got a nice crew there hope
you're doing all right MVR
and things are good for you yeah yeah we
always you know a fan of when Maxine
plays and oh 95 winning a pawn so you
see Jose he's very disappointed by what
just happened F7 hanging he push the
pawn G6 Falls and each takes a pawn and
he's up a couple seconds now the time's
even Simon this is a position that could
come down to this Knight hate what is
that
it's beautiful that's what it is you put
a good night in the most stupid Square
on the board and you dominate the center
of the board I mean uh it's it's nice
play right
that was beautiful he just takes out F6
he brings his King back or like pushed
the pawn because he's starting to win E5
the queen side will win the game for
Anish Geary
yeah and there you go and the score is I
think that's it we're into overtime oh
is this the last game no no I think
you're right we're I mean it doesn't
matter either way because you have to
win by two so these players get no rest
I think this is a good thing Simon you
know we don't like to be taken out of
rhythm as chess players so brakes and
bullet actually are more of a
distraction than anything
maybe Jose would like to be taken out of
rhythm here because he's going against
him right he could do the rest and you
need to get a two-point lead just to
remind everyone and all my words what
was he done he just blundered a piece
yeah he blooded and they don't see Forks
the queen 92 was loose and he is beside
himself you're right Simon you know I
kept saying oh you want to keep playing
you want to be in the Rhythm but the
Rhythm isn't only going in niche's way
right now
it is neat and look at look at nisha's
concentration he looks so absorbed into
the game this should be his game and if
a niche finish wins this game he just
needs to win the next one there was a
nice idea there it looked like Brooke
takes Paul was going to be Checkmate but
white could take with check there this
is a much better way of doing it it's
going to be a whole Rook up there last
trick there from Jose the next game key
Robert yeah and for Jose he if he knows
the rules a draw is okay you just cannot
lose the game it's hard to even draw in
bullet with no increment because the
time scrambles you don't know what's
going to happen there but we see that
it's a one point lead slightly for Anish
giri in the driver's seat but do they
know that's what I really am wondering
they must know that it's both double
elimination and win by two
they must know the rules I mean uh I'm
pretty sure uh they they look this up
beforehand I mean it'd be a big blunder
if they didn't and this is the tense
match because yeah white wins it's game
match over Jose needs to get a result
here
White's position though because he's got
the two Bishops he's got this hold on
the queen side if you look at the pawns
on the queen side White's Pawn over
there now the bishop coming in to
support it gives this grip on the
position
Jose is so fast though he's up a couple
seconds and Anish when he needs to turn
on the Jets he does right now the Knight
on C5 covering D7 otherwise The Rook
would Infiltrate The Knight on B5
stopping any B4 Pawn push because C3
would be hanging so I like the way that
Jose is handling this now the Rooks are
off Simon can white do anything because
that pawn on B7 is locked in place
yeah you look at you look at Black's
pawns on the queen side they're all on
light squares what does white have white
has a light Square bishop and that
Bishop can probe nearly every black pawn
and that's why white must have good
chances in this ending but Knights are
tricky pieces right we know in bullet
chess just how dangerous they can be and
there's a check there oh
and look at that night the night has
come and taken upon but how strong is
the Pawn on the edge of the board yeah
it's a big question
you saw that London
but he is up a little bit of time we've
seen him be very fast but this is where
Jose can shine he has 10 seconds to
Anish is 13. can Jose get this done
are you say does this it will be equal
in the match
he should better do it he's playing
quickly he should take the last point
three seconds left the last part
okay it does he does just in time
can't lose now uh he's up on time he's
gonna win the knights are too tricky oh
my goodness what speed from the both and
Jose equals this matchup
how quick was that at the end insanely
quick I mean uh that was that was just
crazy so they are now level again
and uh you need that two-point lead
another big game and we need more mvl in
the chat because yeah we are getting
extra content for free and this position
oh H3 was a free Pawn but Simon that's
one of those pawns where you take it and
then you immediately regret grabbing it
yeah I mean you take the pawn but you
might get checkmated
agreedy that seemed a little bit greedy
to me
because that Bishop is also completely
trapped and there it goes white is gonna
just take the bishop that was a hot Pawn
Way Too Hot oh so a niche trying to
generate some counter play
it's not enough clearly he's gonna keep
trying to throw up that night's coming
to C3 though so it shouldn't be enough
from the point of view of objective
chess but this is a bit annoying for
white to deal with
it is and I think it's gonna be who gets
the attack I like what White's done
though white has closed the position
down and now it's White's turn to attack
that is a beautiful last move and the
black king will now be opened up white
putting his Bishop his light Square
Bishop on that square that was a
brilliant idea
it's changed a bit again though black is
defending well over D7 is a threat and
Rook takes G6 or Pawn takes G6 with this
is over because the F7 Pawn was pinned
so this is simple at this stage for Jose
he pushes all of his pawns and one of
them will Queen so the good news for a
niche he still gets more games because
it's win by two so maybe Niche thinks
you know that he needs to keep playing
this out I would just resign he has and
he is right back into the next bullet
game
again we have a must win situation but
this time it is a niche who needs to win
the game and that must be a bit
psychologically strange Robert don't
think as you know before you had that
safety barrier there's no safety barrier
for Niche anymore
no there isn't and it's game four of six
in the additional games and if it's tied
out for the six games as you see on the
screen front of you then it becomes
sudden death so Anish he needs to get
this one he needs to equalize this
matchup but because they can't play
Forever like if you're trading off
victories and it's 1.0 like you know in
tennis with the advantage the deuce at
some point someone needs to to win and
right now it looks like Jose Martinez is
is in charge but Anish with the white
piece in this game I like it for him
yeah he's uh very good in the ending as
well and he shouldn't he's got a better
Pawn structure here if you look at
Black's pawns over on the king side that
H Pawn of blacks is a potential weakness
black has done a great job of bringing
his King over there that was a clever
maneuver
and now he's just trying to swap off
pieces here
okay fine very equal as well yeah this
Knight comes in D3 there is Bishop D6
that walks in a rook D7 with a pin the
Knight I believe is just better and
there it goes F7 is falling
I think anisha's gonna get this one
he definitely should he's just scooping
upon oh Knight C4 that's the night The
Rook
drops back to equal again oh my gosh
how many games have they played Robert
I'm I'm struggling to keep up with their
score now yeah it's 10 f10fs or 21 games
played Simon it's great that this was
the last match that you know they say it
saved the best for last this is clearly
our best match of the day
yeah it is indeed so do we need to have
a two-point lead still that's why I'm
trying to work out have they played six
games yet I'm not sure uh we no we know
this is game five and we will not need a
two-point lead because as soon as the
six additional games are up if someone
has the lead I believe that ends the
match so uh right now Anish playing very
solidly both players have frankly been
as solid as it gets that Rook on D5
though that's annoying for black DeWitt
that's a lovely Square for white in the
center of the board and uh Anish now
kicking that Rook away but you can grab
a pawn instead he keeps it very simple
and just activates his Queen here
slightly better for white though because
you have this Central Square that you
can potentially get your knight into
it's a bit unpleasant for flat to play
agreed and that's why and he's just
pushing his pawns but he's keeping D5
under control F5 also under control
and only now 94 is going to be a pain
good play from a niche maybe in the zone
the Queens are coming off
both ways activating their kings here
and black definitely better because
white has this useless
um extra Pawn on the queen side but
Black's extra porn can become a passport
yes an A4
being dominated as well Robert this is
that super GM technique Bortnick is in
the chat what's up Alexander saying what
a match awesome I don't think this is
awesome for Jose right now because black
is actually up a pawn even though the
material is even look at those Queen
side pawns well now they're dropping off
now it's two extra pawns for black the a
pawn it's The Little Engine That Could
that's promoting Simon you know what
that's gonna mean if Anish can pull this
off Jose maybe oh what a blunder oh
what happened there he took and he
allowed to leave it and he's it has
changed again it's back to a niche
winning with mate I can't believe it my
heart is palpitating and you see that
Jose shakes his head he needs to win
this game it's the sixth game of
additional overtime chess if he does not
win then Anish Geary moves on in the
winners bracket
so if it's a draw does that mean a niche
goes through as well yeah I believe it
does yes
okay so Jose must win with the black
pieces the thing is it's too quick to
even say a sentence Robert as soon as we
say a sentence the evaluation has
changed that's how quick this match is
uh this this match has been so awesome
to see but right now look at that knight
in black space B5 is coming black
players instead but now C6 oh what a
positional eyesore
yeah that's a big Target for anisha's
pieces and uh he's dominating that side
of the board he gets a little tactic in
there
you might have to go up the exchange
though
oh no he's making more exchanges first
but now Knight C5 if D takes C5 there's
still Queen takes D5 these positions may
still be decent for white because look
at that C6 Pawn those double Rooks for
black are staring into your own Pawn so
they're defensive rather than aggressive
pieces
but it is still the exchange and if
black can ever activate his Rooks what
you need to do when you've got the extra
Rook or the extra exchange is just open
up files so maybe a push of the Pawn in
the center at the right moment will
allow one of the black Rooks to get on
an open file just open up the lines for
your Rooks don't worry if you lose a
pawn doing it yeah look at the clock
Jose is well ahead in time he plays E5
F3 player but that's not going to get it
done it looks like it's a winning ending
for Black maybe Rock A4 at the right
moment trying to trade off those Rooks
could be good
we could get a sudden death game after
this I mean it looks like it's just an
extra Rook here there's enough time that
means it's all in the next game right
what if it's if it's a draw it just
keeps going until one side wins right
that's correct we have sudden death at
this stage and Anish you know he knows
he's losing this one do the players
actually get a break or do they keep
going that's the big question
they're not allowed it breaks
straight in you know they're Gladiators
you can't give them a break so whoever
wins the next game will go through to
the next round oh my God I'm nervous
honestly like it's not even my match I'm
just commentating but I feel the energy
the Jitters from the players and right
now we have a situation like we saw
before Simon white has these double
pawns black has a healthier Pawn
structure uh but this position it says
it's about even according to the engines
and now we have different minor pieces
for each side
I bet we get six drawers in a row now
that would be just to keep the tension
going this match has been so dense so
far and who's better here I mean I I
like black because he's controlling the
open file black has the better Pawn
structure and his Knight looks good so
even though the evaluation Bar says it's
even black has the better pieces I
suppose the black king is a bit weaker
though oh and he's blundered a pawn you
can see a niche clearly really annoyed
with that move he's giving away a very
important Pawn white has now two strong
pawns oh dear Robert that was a major
mistake there it was and you could see
it in his eyes like his eyes lit up as
soon as he allowed Queen A7 first and
then he'll have this queen shred and now
it's all Jose and this is going to be
disappointing the look at the White
Pines they've stuffed all of Black's
pawns removing
yeah I've got a great blockade with
white pawns Jose looks so focused at the
moment not showing any emotion if he can
get the king into the position
it's got to be game over and look at the
white king the white king is just
munching
Munch Munch Munch yeah the hungry King
and I think that's gonna be it
wow what a match that was Jose look at
it look at him celebrate there and he
deserves every ounce of that celebration
you could tell he put his entire heart
and soul every last ounce of energy into
those final stretch of games so
congratulations to Jose Martinez who
advances to the winners quarterfinal
that was amazing that that was what our
bullet chess championships are about
close matches Fighting Chess you've got
to feel a bit sorry for a niche it could
have gone either way that much but Jose
kept his call the better in in that
tensing
well deserved victory for Jose Martinez
and what's craziest of all is you look
at the score between a nation and Jose
they played seven extra games and those
seven extra games equals hikaru's total
right both matches were 24 games a car
just won so many games so quickly that
he got to 22 and a half assignment that
is absolutely ridiculous when a car was
able to accomplish today
yeah I mean getting that many wins on
the board in the time half an hour I
mean uh it just shows you how quick
Hikaru isn't moving and how good he is
at moving as well so hikara clearly on
good form and uh I think a pretty good
first day Robert don't you pretty
exciting yesterday I love how you you
know you're playing it down you just
want even more excitement tomorrow but
that was such a great opening day it's
not over just yet because well we'll
look at the bracket right now in a few
minutes we'll also be joined by Jose
Martinez for an interview but we see at
the top of the bracket there Hikaru
Nakamura he crushed it he is going to
take on Jose Martinez who had the
stiffest test of the first round taking
on each Geary that match was a nail
butter that we were just having the
privilege to witness but that matchup
should be fun tomorrow between Hikaru
and Jose and the journey does not end
for Anish giri because there is double
elimination there is a loser's bracket
and we see Anish takes on Amino hanyan I
think Anish is the favorite down on the
bottom over there he played so well in
that match today
yes he did he played really well I mean
I I guess he's got to get over that loss
he's going to be very disappointed as
you are but I mean he's been in a
situation many times before and um yeah
that was really the closest match today
by quite some margin the other ones the
other matches went one way uh by a big
margin I'd say and Hikaru the player
would they do we think playing the best
chess getting the biggest score
I think between Andrew Tang you really
loved his chest early today and he beat
on draken so I feel like between the two
of them it's hard to pick just one but
I'm with you that this has been a
stellar performance from the better
seeds they all went on to win but that
last match between Jose Martinez and
Anish gear was that close we will be
joined by Jose on the flip side of this
break do not go anywhere
have a friend or family member who loves
chess give them a chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level
use a gold platinum or Diamond
membership for one month or one year
want your gift to arrive on your
friend's birthday or on a holiday gifts
can be scheduled to arrive up to 90 days
in the future
all premium plans include an ad free
Experience Unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
good
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock app right here almost
there and you did it
oh what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and we are joined by perhaps the man of
the day Jose Martinez with an epic
showdown against Anish giri Jose first
question for you is are you breathing
okay how are you feeling
I'm feeling uh I will almost die soon
I I know like the match will be really
hard I know Anish I I suppose he was
training with some accounts so I I
played some matches he didn't knew it I
know who is with the his Anonymous
account so he's really strong like he is
not an easy opponent in bullet for sure
In classical and other uh time controls
is like a beast uh Elite player top five
but I'm bullet I I get impressed because
he he was playing a lot so I take it
seriously and my prep in
in Sunday no yesterday
yeah it was a really exciting match I
mean everyone was getting very very uh
well they didn't know what was going to
happen in the end and that means your
reward is You're Gonna Play Hikaru in
the next round and what are your
thoughts on uh playing Hikaru next
um if I play Hikaru with the same level
of today I will lose like uh with 10
games in my in a row but I will get
adopted so I need to
um the rest to think about maybe before
the the match and I hope I can like be
in the bullet mood
the correct bullet mood I always be when
I play some tournaments yeah
and I mean Jose you know being able to
relax sounds like it's difficult given
what we just witnessed can you take us
through your mind during the match you
were down early then you stormed ahead
and then Anish came back like how did
you feel the match was going were you
ever really worried that you were gonna
lose
for sure I consider a lot like this
match I think was
50 50 or maybe some Advantage for me
because I always play bullet but I I
consider sometimes I could I can lose
the match but I was really uh dumb I was
really dumb when I was three points
ahead I just relaxed I didn't focus more
I just relax and I think the match will
be over because it was like seven and a
half
against four and a half so I I think I
will win because I guess the time will
be like two minutes or three minutes
left so I just play normal chess you
play excellent I made some mistakes and
then he came back he won three in a row
so he died and I was really really uh at
some point nervous because I didn't
expect it
and um how do you prepare like for a
match like this I mean like let's say
you got an hour or two before the match
starts is there anything you do do you
do some puzzles or or something else to
get in the right mindset
I think uh for bullet you should be like
uh in your five cents uh alert you need
to like be in a
if you're fighting with the lion in The
Jungle you need to be like that you need
to be like so focused and so prepared
for everything and I think today I did I
I was not in that mood I was like
feeling uh tired I think because I maybe
didn't take a bath I didn't eat
breakfast or yeah maybe I need to change
something for tomorrow I don't want to
Chicago to destroy me a lot I want to to
give him a really good match and if I am
in my best shape I
I can
think in America
well one thing you definitely didn't
need to change today is that shirt I
gotta always give it a shout out every
time I see it that you know chess is
more fun with Taco so you know what is
that just your shirt when you're playing
in a serious competition you wear the
fun shirt
I I choose this shirt like a
with us a
how to say it yeah my English is not
good I didn't find the correct word but
with with what's with intention because
yeah I was choosing should I put a
Peruvian shirt should I put that Mexican
shirt and then decide oh I have this I
remember some
nice term and I have went with this
shirt I think in practice League I have
my best performance using this clothes
so yeah I I think it's my
may look a shirt
at least today I have a I have a lot of
luck in the some games
where are the tacos are they nearby
yeah we're in Mexico we love tacos I'm
now in Mexico I'm Peruvian but I'm
living in Mexico for some months so this
sure is uh
it's not like casual it's like I have a
I have the feeling I have the Mexican
food
well you know hopefully you have the
feeling you get the feeling you didn't
eat breakfast go eat some tacos go enjoy
yourself I was able to see you tomorrow
for your matchup against Hikaru
congratulations once again
thank you thank you Robert thank you
Simon
and that is Jose Martinez from Peru in
Mexico taking down super Grandmaster and
nishikiri he is the only person who
qualified into the bullet Chess
Championship to win their opening round
matchup and what a matchup that was the
most exciting by far in the winners
bracket first round
yeah definitely I mean it so so so close
that much I mean there are a number of
great you know players and matches going
on though again I would like to mention
Magnus Carlson you know it's his first
time playing here and uh maybe I'm just
a bit of a Magnus fan but I'm really
looking forward to seeing how he's going
to progress in this competition he
mentioned that he hasn't got his ideals
set up and he's gonna have to play maybe
better tomorrow against Min because uh
that you know that's going to be tough
that one Robert I feel him if he doesn't
come out at Full Speed Ahead
yeah and I've already revised the
question I was going to ask you at least
the one I was planning to ask you so
I'll just ask directly how far do you
think Anish giri can go how deep of a
run do you think he can make from the
losers bracket
good question I mean the way he was
playing in that match he he was getting
the better positions I feel uh if he
wins a couple of times you know I reckon
he could go deep you know he's a he's a
real fighter Anish and that's been
proven by his track record against the
elite players and how well he's done hey
it's Jessica
yeah he really I think proved to a lot
of people there that he can fight with
the best of them in bullet chess that
was a great matchup won by Jose Martinez
shout out to both those players but this
is a 16 person field everyone comes back
tomorrow we will have more amazing
matchups in store for you tomorrow as we
get in to the quarter fines the winners
bracket and into the losers bracket so
don't miss that action that's tomorrow
same time same place and same faces
it'll be me and Simon once more so we
thank you so much for tuning in I hope
you had as much fun as we did and we'll
see you tomorrow from the bullet Chess
Championship 2023.
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hahaha
thank you
[Music]
foreign